hey everybody this episode of the
podcast is brought to you by Squarespace
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
that makes it fast and easy to create
your own professional website used to be
a long time ago it was a real pain in
the ass to get a website if you want to
get a website you had to find someone
who knew how to make one they had a code
it in HTML it was a nightmare and then
they started making these programs like
Dreamweaver and all these are very
difficult to learn and try to figure out
how to put it together and then if it
worked it wouldn't work on certain
platforms now Squarespace has that all
covered and anybody I mean you me any
person can if you can attach a photo to
an email you can make a beautiful
professional-looking website it's very
simple drag-and-drop interface they have
24/7 support there they work on windows
mac pc iphone android very easy to do
about as easy as you can get they also
have it available so that you can create
your own online store quick and easy
created in minutes they have a logo
creator we can create a clean simple
logo design for yourself in minutes
every design automatically includes a
unique mobile experience that matches
your overall style of your website so
your content will look great on every
device at every time and for a free
trial and 10% off your first purchase go
to squarespace.com and enter the code
word jo at squarespace.com and enter the
code word Jo we're also brought to you
by on it onna is a human optimization
website what we sell is strength and
conditioning equipment health and
fitness supplements we just try to sell
what we find to be the best things
available whether it's kettlebells we
sell kettlebells both the regular
kettlebells that we sell and we also
have primal bells and zombie bells these
artistic kettlebells that are the primal
bells are the great ape collection
gorilla orangutan chimp and howler
monkey very cool to look at cool to
hammer on the gym they look good and
they're functional 3d mapped kettlebells
so it's not like they're out of balance
just for the sake of looking cool their
3d balanced
the best kettlebells you can buy and
when you use them you can be content
that when the apocalypse comes these
fucking things will be still here
there's solid metal it will last forever
and they're excellent we sell the best
supplements that we can find the best
hemp forest protein powder we have a new
item called a warrior bar it's made the
ancient Lakota way it's a buffalo
supplement bar so like if you you know
you're on the run and you need to get
some food in your body and you just want
to have a snack that's not negative and
not nasty for you
this warrior bar has 140 calories 4
grams of fat per serving and 14 grams of
protein all healthy no MSG no soy no
lactose no nitrates no antibiotics no
added hormones super super healthy for
you and like all things that on it
we just find whatever we can that is the
best version of whatever that is for
sale and then we sell it we try to sell
it to you at the most reasonable rate
possible if you use the code word Rogan
you will save 10% off any and all
supplements all right why play around
Hicks and Gracie's here ladies and
gentlemen and my brother Eddie Bravo cue
the music Jamie let's get going the Joe
Rogan experience trained by Joe Rogan
podcast by night
[Music]
all right we like first of all thank you
very much for doing this I appreciate it
out of all the people on line when
whenever you know things get brought up
for mixed martial arts guess or
jiu-jitsu gasps it's always get Hicks
and Gracie on the podcast so the the
clouds have parted the Stars have
aligned and you're here and we
appreciate it very much I'm very
thankful to Joe and Eddie to be with you
guys here and have this conversation
it's it's funny because last time we
talked and my house
why we go of course you you make me some
questions you Q use you you all about
knowing what is what has in my mind and
at this point I was the talker and you
know in the past and the time goes by
and today I can see after all this
process of evolutionary process in the
MMA and the martial arts world I mean
since then I've been watching you doing
your job commenting fights analyzing
other fighters and today I can see man
you a red belt in the whole and the
whole extension of the world you know
everything you mean if I have a question
I have it to coach I call you and ask
you what's up because I'm very very I
mean
impressed with your career with your
charisma with the way you you position
your opinions it's all very precise so
I'm very happy to be here and discuss
some talks and talk with you thank you
brother that's an honor to me and it was
an honor for me to hang out with you
that night it was really cool for we had
dinner with your family and then we
watched some fights yeah and it was
really interesting watching fights with
you and watching you break down
positions and break down mistakes that
people were making and I've told a lot
of people about that man I'll tell a lot
of people about that night your that
documentary choked that is one document
that I've told people if you're really
interested in jiu-jitsu you really want
to find out you know what what the
spirit of jiu-jitsu is all about watch
the documentary choke that documentary
is so inspirational they followed you
was in 94 95
yeah 95 going to 96
95 going into 96 and you were fighting
in Japan in the Japan Valley to do--and
it documented a lot of your training and
documented your philosophy and man
whenever if ever I need some motivation
I'll just lock that DVD on you just get
fired up you want to go do some yoga on
the beach or something yeah you know
it's fine
how did that come about what that
documentary Oh was a project with a
student of mine who was working with the
the poly grin and also so he decided we
decided to follow up to the event and so
we we had they have a crew following
couple fighters and and follow myself to
see what's going to happen at the event
so was a nice introduction to a
preparation to the mindset of a fighter
either myself or the Todd Haynes with
another and also that Japanese guy who
was also involved in the and they
filming so was a cool primal experience
true to am MMA fight like I value to the
fight well it's very eye-opening for a
lot of fighters who looked at mixed
martial arts a lot of them come from a
wrestling background and they looked at
mixed martial arts more of like as a
sport just be tough you know you got to
get up you gotta train hard you got to
run hard you got to live hard and your
philosophy was much more like a samurai
your philosophy was much deeper much
more meditation based and we got to see
you doing yoga you you I think you
opened up a lot of people's eyes to
different mindset involved in
preparation but also to yoga that was
the first time I had ever seen a martial
artist that was really into yoga yes I
think for the athlete in general the
breathing understanding of the breathing
is a big plus because stretch or your I
mean by hyperventilate you stretch your
physical potential by know how to
breathe properly you relaxed you can
bring your heart heartbeats lower is a
lot of elements in the breathing who are
involved with controlling emotions
getting more energy and so on so as I
get exposed to breath too
reading properly I get addicted and I
felt like was a huge element of you know
to in addition to the techniques in
addition to the heart and to the heart
training learning the breathing is a
huge beneficial thing for the athlete
now you see athletes like tennis players
they who they play in breathing and the
breathing the breath is much more into
the sport today so it's a process of no
and now I see clone my son he's I mean
before he's just like CEO that I see you
training and breathe but now he's coming
to me said that make all the difference
in the world when I really you know
starts getting tired to make
hyperventilation and keep my mind like
sharp because sometimes if you get tired
there's not enough oxygen in the blood
to fuel your your sharpness in your mind
so you become a little stupid a little
slower you know so by having a good
knowing how to hyperventilate you're
able to to maximize this this oxygen so
even though there's logic take over your
body your mind is too sharp and you
still responding accordingly so it's a
great thing to do and you were born into
the greatest jiu-jitsu family the
greatest martial arts family of all time
I mean there's no doubt about it there's
no there's not even a second place
there's the Gracie family and then
there's you know this is a I guess you
could have a debate about who comes in
second but it's kind of ridiculous that
is the number one martial arts family of
all time and you obviously learned
jujitsu from a very early age but how
did you get involved into the yoga
always you know was I'm very happy to to
be related with this master call Orlando
Connie which was the precursor of the
genus kana to da I was learning in the
same time
Alvaro hermano who is the guy who is now
making the tape so we learning together
you know and at that point was just
practicing with him like helo made my
father he's a water guy who's a very
tough athlete and also yoga teachers so
he combined
he developed some kind of style of yoga
which is not exactly a postural like
postures and breathing to relax or to
achieve meditation was more like a at
the active breathing for athletes and in
order for you to jump higher you have to
know how to to have our mony between
your your jump and your breathing you
want to keep more strength for more a
long time you have to know how to
breathe a quarterly to to promote that
so here as always he always in the
active active breathing and then we kind
of we started doing privates and I was
in his place for you know for couple of
months he's guiding me through the the
moves in front of a mirror in a nice
room one day we about to start the class
and soon who is about to start
he he was calling the phone and he said
to me Hickson you keep going and I'll be
right back
so for the first time I was able to
breathe make my routine without follow
him up without having my mind focused
and what he was doing so I started to
breathe and move and breathe and move
and then we had some woods on the walls
kinda we can imitate monkeys to climb
the wood and stuff so in one point I
come back to reality and then I was on
top of the highest frame in the wall
sweating like a pig and then I look
around and start to come back to reality
and I saw him on the corner crying and
then I said what's up man what's going
on I said man you don't have to learn
anything else from me you achieve the
highest level of kept get empty mind and
then I kind of said why say that said
yeah because you here for an hour 50
minutes and completely off I mean you
didn't notice anything because he was
applying the development of the animal
instinct which takes your brain off your
your mind your your concentration and
keep you more like a instinctive animal
and that's what's the the
and through this because before that I
was doing Transcendental Meditation I
did traditional yoga and and those never
did great for me in the meditation I was
sleeping and it's not by doing that kind
of routine I was able to not just
breathing properly but also achieve
empty mind and I was like in a state a
meditation meditation state for a long
time like not concentrating in anything
like rational oh he's there or he's so I
was able to get achieve like I empty
mine and after I noticed that I start to
practice my routines to to get that same
feeling of emptiness and that kind of
meditation works for me as no no other
one and I felt like being an empty mind
increases my my I don't know my
intuition increases my my sense of of
energy and so what's incredible for me
because I could get in touch more
comfortably with my I mean my third
vision I don't know exactly explain but
I could achieve a completely peace of
mind in that kind of routine so I was
stick for life so you just got into this
state and you could just exist no
conscious thought no thinking about
anything around you no past no future
just exist is in our moment with no
contact yes and that's a kind of weird
positive feeling because you capable to
be present in a sense which if you have
your mind set if you have something
expectations or or you never there so I
was able to to be very confident very
easily to get into that situation where
even prior the fight I'm able to sleep
on the on the locker room making my
workout getting a high very high
heartbeat and then like five minutes
before I make my praise I make my
meditation and I kind of cool off my
heartbeat to 60 60 heartbeats a minute
so I was able to engage very hot and
with the heart very hard
no heartbeat and as the fight progress
the pace is very hard if I'm sixty he is
80 when I'm 80 he's a hundred when I'm a
hundred he's a hundred to any when I'm
120 he's a 45th so when he started we
have to regroup I was still having to go
forward so and that point my opponents
always lose a little bit his pay so at
that time for me to make the kill you
know so was always working properly for
me the breathing was always working very
well so this empty mind stay enhanced
your jiu-jitsu this ability to achieve
this state on top of all the techniques
on top of all the training and the
instincts this took it to the next level
yes because you know in one point if you
allow yourself to be present you not
commit to the offense or the defense you
commit you give nothing and take
everything so you give me opportunity I
will be there if you try to be
surprising me I will be there a
quarterly defending myself so it's all
on the table is like no surprises
because there's no expectations so
keeping a cool mind even when it's
boiling is something I felt like was
always like something which give me an
edge because I was there just to either
catch what is there or resolved the
problem never disappoint or never late
no expectation yeah and it's always late
I mean sometimes you get late because
you playing something in a fight and
doesn't happen so if Paul is you start
to be disappointed so for me it was
always like whatever happened I'm there
I'm happy comfortable finding
comfortable finding the sharpness true
to achieve success you know so you grew
up in this jiu-jitsu family but you were
always at least from most people's
interpretation you were always the best
guy out of the family how did that
happen how did you rise above all the
rest I mean you grew up with a bunch of
killers yes everybody's training hard
everybody was pushing to the maximum and
for one point I feel like I was dead
get it and for perfectionist I'm
competitive in my heart but some
elements I get was more like a god a god
gift is not exactly something I choose
so we training out the same why my
brother I can play with my ball brothers
and they cannot have a chance with me so
that's kind of hard to explain it's not
me trying to do this this just happened
it's my is myself being trying to be my
best plus the emotional control the
peace of mind it was all you know for
example my love my my beloved brother
hilar he's a great fighter but sometimes
they get too emotional you know and
thats kind times makes him choose the
hoenn the wrong path so choice here's a
you know great fighter but sometimes he
he get a little confused
he's not having the sharp offensive
attitude doors so sometimes something
sleep you know and so on so I not
exactly know why I'm I'm the one I just
have to represent and be you know happy
to be the one and I tell you man all the
opportunities I have to represent I did
already so I feel like completely
comfortable and in myself saying okay I
have nothing to prove to myself I did
all and you know I'm very happy with the
results so jiu-jitsu for life for life
indeed that's an on Jamie your you had a
cousin holes Gracie the legendary holds
great who's actually holds is Indiana
he's Mike my cousin but he was living in
my house since I born because my uncle
as he his he divorced from his wife he
hollered halls mother he give my father
was just get marry so he give halls true
to be
care to my father and mother so he was
like a brother so he's my older brother
because Harden coming just after and
then how soon and then when I born like
8 years 9 years later I was the the
little one
living with hogs hot and in house and
for a full you know so is my brother is
no way to see him differently he was
known as a guy who went all over the
world studied Sambo studied us some
catch wrestling his wrestlers and he
would bring that back right yes
what would you credit holes in in
bringing leg locks in to Brazilian
jiu-jitsu is he the one yes I mean the
leg locks he specifically was not
something I I kind of get the the major
information from halls was funny one day
Eric Paulson was a good student and a
very good friend
he brought a tape for me from Japan
we've we've shot - mm-hmm shot -
wrestling and I saw did the knee locks
in the show - wrestling you know some
guys fighting and I saw and I kind of
interesting and then next day I start to
apply it and then what's funny because
he comment to me afterwards said he you
mean I give you the tape one day next
day we're submitting everybody on the
knee locks oh really yeah well you you
would say you learn more leg locks from
Eric Paulsen tape than holes yeah I mean
it was not specifically I let lock guy
you know there's a picture of him with a
sambar surety yeah yeah study he was a
master of Sambo because no no we go in
sambal as we go and any other we go in
representing jiu-jitsu against sambal
you know and in the pan-american games
we went in San Diego was like very
interesting because the fighters they
don't expect so much submissions and we
start immediately because tough
wrestlers tough judo players so we start
immediately bringing the fight to the
ground ground and go four foot locks and
knee locks and immediately
I mean in the first qualification phase
they started tapping a lot and then the
referee's statue becomes kind of little
skeptical about that they start to
become one
so once halls grabbed them and then the
footlok especially in the in the final
match in his weight division he get the
guy in the footlocker the referee
stopped the fight and said now you
cannot get the foot lock on the joint
you have to get on like on the shin and
then it's kind of confusing you know and
cutting the that's why halls lost the
finals in this event and this is what in
the 70s was I think eighties so they
just they were trying to cut him out by
yeah the referee started getting upset
because like was funny we supposed to
come in with a team from Brazil of 12
guys and we spare expecting like a
support from the government and then the
governor at the very last very last
moment didn't didn't give to us so my
father paid us to come so just me Carlos
Gracie Joyner and hogs so we come in to
compete in this event and hold were you
at this time you must have been like 18
or something
yes 19 or something like that and then
we coming and I was in the like my
weight division which is 1 above halls
and halls was below me and Carlos was on
top of me
so we kind of having one in each
division and as the competition progress
the referees that you see those three
guys from Brazil just submitting
everybody because in Samba chokes are
not allowed no headlocks no CH no color
chokes use only knee locks foot locks or
straight arm bars cannot even do the
Americana's because goes English so we
just go in trying to do foot locks
because those are the easiest way so we
start to finish the guys and they start
to say oh this guy's coming and do food
and everybody may complain I don't know
if but a Samba though isn't somehow
worth it yeah that's what I do is
footlong it's now now back then there
wasn't fair it's it's it's so
interesting how wait a minute that's
changed no was legal what was not used
especially in the Samba in American
concepts Russia maybe yeah you know
American song
focus on what mostly they are more like
him to control the rules are if you pin
the guy for 30 seconds it was like
wrestling not as it's longer but he was
to win like judo and as you if attempt
the peon every time the guy passes the
back on the ground you're still making
points so in my final match I guess the
guy from the air force very strong guy
which maybe rascally and judo background
and he was whipping my ass man he's just
like in the first like three rounds
three minutes in the first round he stay
on top all the time and because being in
the guard you losing points
the score is about twelve or fourteen
points in the first round in the second
round is about eighteen or twenty I tell
you in the very final round I was about
26 or something points against zero you
know and I was just trying to do my
thing and then one like maybe a minute
before the very final man round I slap
him and mounted and he is at the same
time I mounted he's tried to push me
away and I get like a moving arm lock
and he's not even tap he's just yell so
and then I win the fight like in a very
final second and you were down twenty
something yes like points are not even
chance I thought I'm not there to
winning by points I was there just to
see if I can submit it's it's
fascinating and then the guy tapped like
15 seconds before the fight is in and
then like the whole crowd was and then
everything kind of whoo and then just
few guys fun
so when Eric Paulson showed you these
tapes of shootout in the 90s probably
you already you were already doing leg
locks a little bit I'm not really I very
like foot locks I always like straight
foot lock yes and then what Eric Paulson
showed you was like fancy knee bars and
stuff yes because from the guard you
just spin around and go with a straight
knee law yeah so I get a may I get
amazed by this kind and I start to
develop you know very quickly was just
adapt to my game and was an
an addition to the the Arsenal you know
what's great it's funny when you look
back at old Eric Paulsen fights from
Japan you look at the stuff he was doing
and people today still aren't even doing
that he's way ahead of the game to it
Eric Paulsen was an encyclopedia
submissions him and Matti home yep those
guys back then it looked like like
advanced jujitsu and of course you know
anytime you got the mount there was
always an armbar you know yeah buts
about that but you know at that time
Eric was being training very
consistently for us he's a good good
brother in a training partner who's
always being a great warrior and I have
a lot of respect for him great guy very
very knowledgeable yeah isn't it
fascinating that we've seen just in the
time that I started training it from 96
on this adoption of leg locks in jujitsu
yes in the early in the 90s it used to
be that leg locks were frowned upon when
someone went for leg locks people get
really upset Hickson were you at the
first Pan American Games in 1996 in or
1997 here in El Segundo in LA you must
have been there right do you remember
that yes
there was the first Pan Americans there
was like 500 Brazilians they shipped
them all they and there was the crazy
thing is I was a blue belt in jujitsu
and I saw ken Shamrock tape of a photo
hold so I was a blue belt doing toe
holds jean-jacques Machado's academy and
i competed in the tournament and so did
Eric Paulson and when I went for a
toehold in this tournament all the
Brazilians started throwing there was
almost a riot they called the cops never
throwing shoes at me and Johnnie Machado
I'll never forget him running and
slow-motion sliding and I had the tone
and Johnny goes you gotta let it go you
gotta let slide the toehold and I'm
looking around so I let it go people are
throwing shoes at me and water bottles
and stuff it was like a big deal and I
ended up losing I let it go and
afterwards
Eric Paulson's in the parking lot it was
just me and him he was a blue belt as
well and he was like his kid we were
like the same age but he was like I was
like a little kid he's like you know let
me talk to you kid and goes let me show
you a couple leg locks so he showed me a
couple things like this weirdest leg
lock that doesn't work and he admits it
now that it was garbage but he showed me
this leg lock he showed me this
Glock will you go like this is weird
thing in the parking lot
and I'll never forget that it's like man
this guy's the only guy who understands
that that I liked old and and he was on
my podcast not too long ago and he said
and I asked him about that movie do you
remember that movie goes oh yeah it's
it's garbage it's trash how these ideas
they get innovated and within our
lifetime they started getting
implemented and they get weeded out the
ones that work wind up staying the ones
that don't work fall by the wayside what
do you think about the IBJJF banning
heel hooks that's a good thing I like I
like to first of course the pleasure to
talk about all this and I can answer
that because I feel like the Hugh hooks
has to be implementing the top level
fighters because that is a solid
technique but because it is designed to
stretch the ligaments not the joint is a
different between you going in your
finger this way is gonna you wanna feel
pain before it brokes yeah but if you go
this way you're gonna resistant to pops
so it's just ligaments it's not a joint
this is a joint this is a ligament so
when you twist the knee the guy can
still resist and when he feels are gonna
fill the pot it's not gonna feel the
pain chew tap so this is in a way if you
don't have the experience you wanna bust
your knee so we don't want to see guys
with busted knees just because they
tough or just because they don't know so
we for beat in a hole the Hugh hooks but
in the in an advanced at level like
metamoris or like premium pros a Budda
Budda
I think they should back bring back in
because this is part of the game and you
have to be responsible to let a broke or
tap and especially a guy like Toki know
when you see Paul Harris he's such a
master at it it's exciting to watch that
guy fight to see how guys are gonna deal
with that well Abu Dhabi still allows
heel hooks right allows your metamours I
my experience I've been teaching now ten
years and we've I allow Hill hooks from
day one only because I as an instructor
I don't want some leglock guy coming
into my school and tapping everybody out
with leg locks so I wanted all my guys
to be very well versed in leg locks and
in my experience we reap we kill hook
white belts I can't even tell you the
last time someone got hurt from a heel
hook I can't I don't even know maybe
maybe once in ten years yeah that that
kind of education its kind of positive
because give the guy the sense he has to
if he feels the problem has to tap in
advance yeah you cannot allow to the pop
happen because you're gonna bust your
knee and Onaga and grapplers quest they
allow heel hooks and you rarely ever
hear about anybody getting hurt I think
I think once you learn how to defend it
it's actually people don't want it
people will tap generally and some
people that don't tap like Gary tonin
was talking about the first time as
someone got him in a heel hook and his
knee popped a few times he thought well
if I tap now it already popped why
should that tap I should just keep going
now and if someone I think if someone's
gonna let their knee pop or get hurt I
think it's their responsibility to tap
and and if it pops is is it really a big
deal I mean it's part of the game people
get hurt people get their knees blown
out in basketball
way more than jiu-jitsu again soccer
yeah I again in 10 years I I can't even
tell you that maybe leg compressions a
couple times guys have had their knees
pop from leg compressions and even
locked down I've had a couple guys get
their knee popped but Hugh hooks and
reaping that's not something that I ever
had to say we got to slow down be
careful with the knee Reeves just no one
really gets hurt what seems to be a
technique that when people were ignorant
of it that's when people are really
getting hurt yeah yeah well sometimes
Kwan when they really want to go for the
heart they don't want they don't
visualize that the possibilities should
hurt so they go and go full power from
the beginning to the end so it's not
even a chance to the guy tap he's
already tapping late so that's more like
the mindset of the the guy who's
attacking if he wants to break your knee
is a great chance to do that in a human
and when we were adding wrestling to our
jujitsu classes trying to combine it now
we separate we have separate wrestling
classes and separate jiu-jitsu class but
at a time when I was trying to combine
it together we would have a day where we
just do wrestling and we do live
wrestling drills and while standing up
that's where everyone got hurt and it
got to a point where collided with each
other just trying to take someone down a
tackling a man they plant on their leg
wrong Einstein broke his leg wrestling
his leg broke because he planted on it
wrong got picked up so there came a
point where I decided you know what too
many guys are getting hurt on wrestling
day so I cut wrestling out and you know
if you want to Russell you go to the
wrestling class in my class is just
jiu-jitsu but we do allow reaping we do
allow heel hooks and there's no one
getting hurt from that more from the
wrestling this is a famous match where
you had with Mark Schultz know what was
what happened in that because that's a
very famous encounter and there's a
movie coming out called Foxcatcher
that's based on do you know the story
behind this movie what was the guy's
name that was responsible Fox catcher it
was based on there was the two brothers
the other one Mark Schultz David Schultz
named Schultz got killed and it's um
it's based on this guy John DuPont who
is this crazy rich guy who was taking
these wrestlers and he was some weird
gay shit there was something weird about
he'd pay for private he would well not
just that he set up a training center
and pay them a lot of money and just get
real weird with him wrestle with these
guys but it was like this old dude you
know wasn't like he was like you know a
guy was really fitting really into
training and learning techniques it was
real weird and he wound up shooting they
creep through every now and then well he
was a billionaire he was super super
rich guy so this this movie is actually
about to come out now but his brother
Mark Schultz was fought in the UFC
Olympic gold medalist fantastic wrestler
like all-time great wrestler and you and
he had an encounter yeah well I was in
in Utah visiting my
my structor Pedro Pedro Sauer yes and
then we are invited to watch the BYU
where he was coaching the the rest
wrestling team there and as I get there
you know looking to for training stuff
and eventually he said ok let's train a
little bit and then immediately we
engage immediately he went to my guard
and almost immediately he's stepping out
and then he was not happy at all they
put him in a triangle or a normal
triangle first from the guard yes and
then he becomes a little more smart and
he can become it so was a long second
round and eventually I went to his back
and submit him again and after a few few
sessions I make him tap some and and he
was very impressed like well nobody did
this with me I mean what's going on I
mean he was stronger than me I mean of
course a warrior and he was not happy I
mean somebody said once you show me a
good loser and I show you a loser so he
was not happy at all
and of course and I understood that and
but eventually he he's cero and he
understood was a technique involved and
he starts to become training with Pedro
and become passionate about jiu-jitsu he
training a lot and he become like a
supporter of the jiu-jitsu cause in Utah
and and you know was a great experience
because I can felt like the whole level
of training and I mean body control he
has but it's still like at that point
the wrestlers has no clue what is you
know submission so what's kind of you
know a surprising thing for them which
doesn't happen those days do you
remember specifically what moves holes
brought from wrestling and and from
Sambo to a good weight distribution a
good ways to like if the guy grabbed you
you able to chew to make the movement
you go to his back like a good turnovers
a good excellent sense of nogi based
control good grapes to charm dragon
stuff yeah things like a very you know
he was training a lot with Bob Bobby Bob
Anderson yes yeah so he was a good
friend of Bob Anders so in Woburn went
to Brazil so it was like he was the one
who brought the wrestling ideas and
concepts because he pushes wants to
compete in Olympic wrestling so was
hauls was always for me a reference you
know as I growing up he was the champion
and he was just unbelievable guy with a
good heart and passion for jiu-jitsu
loved represent and he was my idol you
know as I growing up and I try to follow
his footsteps and as I growing up we all
train hard amount each other we fathers
so my goal was bit helps you know my
goal was be better than him and let's
suppose our last 30 training maybe he he
beat me like in the first two or three
and then we spent maybe 20 trainings or
maybe twenty five trainings step even up
like back and forth I start to get more
and more into his game and what this is
strategy to to catch me and I start to
become a more comfortable in the
surviving and then in one point I start
to getting the advantage in the training
because no luck either you better or not
so inconsistently I start to become more
comfortable and then eventually I start
to getting the advantage in some
positions and then in one day and then
in the range of my father is like and we
can we all get together has a huge match
so I was training with him and I submit
him first time you know what you get him
one oh man was like HM you know here
noogie we so you're not even remember I
think was some kind of joke or something
but what I remember it was
the feeling I felt by achieving my goal
I was making him feel like he was losing
his position and I felt the same way I
felt happy I felt sad because was not
his anymore is myself my responsibility
now and we know that and nobody in the
news
I mean nobody knew I mean of course
people saw the training but at that
point I felt like I was there to support
him but I was better than him and we
still competing in the events coming and
we always closed the bracket because he
goes in his way division I go in mind
and we go together in the open division
so we always closed the open you know
and I never will fight it I mean up to
that day he always been the first and
I'm the second the meadow is his even
though I knew I could maybe change this
you know I never ever will if he's too
alive he will be the number one and I'm
number two based on respect based in
yaki so once he passed away I have to
take over you know and represent fully
and but was I mean he is my inspiration
and it's a great guy he miss him dearly
he died in a tragic hang gliding
accident
how old were you at that time I was
maybe 20 22 something like that so he
was there when you fought Zulu yes he
was he was my coach he was in my corner
with my dad from for people out there
that don't know what I'm talking about
the Zulu match that you had was one of
the that's like watching an old ally
match can you put that up Jamie do you
actually versus ulu yes yes I you know
this conversation goes very well and I I
mean I really appreciate you talking
about the past but I like to make a
little pause on this and and really
bring up the the most because we have to
live today we have to be motivated and
very happy today to come here to explain
and talk about this new venture I'm
involved with which is the new JJ GF
jiu-jitsu global Federation because
talking about jiu-jitsu talking about
rules talking about the future of
jiu-jitsu I think we're having a huge
problem to be resolved you know and
that's is crucial for the future I see
like this new organization will bring to
the table the elements to resolve our
problem you know I think our biggest
problem today in the jiu-jitsu community
is losing effectiveness we've been
losing effectiveness drastically from
the last 15 years because the way in
order for us to restore effectiveness I
felt very appealing to me to engage in
this venture which through this
Federation we're gonna try to resolve
three important I mean we have three
pillars of of action to try to resolve
that problem jiu-jitsu has an
effectiveness in what an MMA effective
and like a fight nono effectiveness I'm
gonna explain to you because it's
different efficiency and effectiveness
today I see the top camp champions very
efficient on getting medals but they
losing effectiveness in real life and
and if you see Jitsu as I grow up the
core of jiu-jitsu was self-defense isn't
preparing the student to handle
situations today the evolutionary
process of jiu-jitsu brought the sport
of jiu-jitsu in those rules diminishing
that effectiveness in the search for the
medal so and like nothing can be boring
for me
more boring then watch some fights in
jiu-jitsu tournaments those days I
believe it I mean they can choose
between stepping the break or stepping
on the on the gas they can choose
because the rules favor if you is
strategically correct you may gonna go
in the fight to fight off a situation
where you can control the pace of the
fight
you can managing the whole tank and
eventually by one or two moves you get
advantage and win the medal so great you
have the medal but sometimes that shows
a lack of desire to compete a lack of
desire to engage in a fair fight
a lot of times I see a white belt or a
blue belt or a purple belt fight which
is much more appealing has much more
open situations of changing positions
then a black belt who sometimes sit on
the floor and is stacked like an
opposition who holds stalling the whole
action so by doing that he's efficient
on get the medal but he's losing
effectiveness to handle real life that's
why it's hard to see a jujitsu
representative on the cage who
translates that I mean I see you should
translate today something I feel like I
never will fight like that the guys
jiu-jitsu practitioner for life his
great is talent he's tough he's
sometimes a champion but he don't fight
the way I believe supposed to be
fighting there you know he has no idea
of clinching he has no idea of sidekick
he has no idea of a volley to the guard
they have a sportive guard all the time
trying to do a more Plata's in you know
instead and the guy on top just hamming
them down so it's kind of weird because
without that kind of efficiency I mean
I'm sorry effectiveness huge it was
losing you know he's losing the
integrity the whole culture the whole
concepts I trust and I believe all my
life so if I can clarify your issue is
with points and with advantage points
yes for example the
this new situation will be this
Federation is not there to compete with
other organizations I'm not there - I'm
doing the job who has not done yet you
know based on this platform this state
of the arm platform we try to have three
different elements to work with the
information I think the vision is to
perform something a good service my
intention with this is to serve the
community in the sport community the
worldwide jiu-jitsu community in this
part of jiu jitsu thinking that I have
three different elements the first one
is the communication aspect information
through the site you're gonna have a
listing of all the academies on the
planet we have a listing of all at
athletes profiles downloads of fights so
they will have the all the option to
request sponsors show themselves it's
like a Google / Facebook for the
community and also we're gonna have a
Masters Council which brings all the
guys who have traditionally spent their
lives in in in the Jewish community to
have a voice active voice for the
community so in the forum's sometimes
somebody makes a question about the
opposition so the Masters will be
involving answers if they want and they
will be Ray highlighted because that's
his opine and that's my opinion so
people the community gonna start to
evaluate what's beneficial and what's
negative what the master has to say so
creates a network which is much needed
to unify the community I see the
community - they completely split you
know they did some federations have
their own circuit some others so it's 30
30 events one side another 30 on the
other side and then has you know Naga
seven grep requests have dream have
IBJJF
so all this is completely disorganized
and completely split so my intention is
bring to the community a sense of of
unification based on this information
who is goal for every like another
important point is have contributors
from all over to bringing their reports
of what's happening in this event who is
the champion who is that a new use and
everything so because some magazines
today they completely partial they just
will talk and explain about their
athletes or in their society does not
cover the whole community so to this
information this solid efficient general
information the general the whole
community will be informed will be
connected will be asking and being
listened so I think that's a very
important for the community
another big pillar of our our Federation
is the competition aspect which by
changing rules we restore effectiveness
how we do that
cutting the advantages because that
venters for me is like a a bow in the
ring it's just touch the ring doesn't
make a point how you gonna make a half
point or is its they're very hard to
interpretate what is really real and
what is not was almost I mean doesn't
matter how many goals you try and hit
the post this score is what matters you
know so a half point just creates a
controversy and interpretation for the
referee fault so becomes a very confused
way so back to the reality you just go
for clear points and also another
important thing is give - points for
stalling positions what is a stalling
position is a position where you hold
with the intention to preserve the
position to preserve the control of the
dynamic of the fight you stalling
because you want to be in control by you
what I call untied shoe Jitsu move which
prevents you from at keep action because
the idea is both engage and see who is
the best who is submit who is passing
who is mounting who is getting and
sometimes people to minimize that risk
they kind of keeping the the situation
under control the position they can
control the sleeves pulling the leg and
tangled it so he's comfortable to to
proceed until the point he needs to make
a little advance so this diminish the
effectiveness because this kind of
strategy doesn't work in real life
so that will punished for that the
piensa me grabbing yes so they grab in
the referee come and say hey man watch a
grip after 20 seconds he already got a
minus point after then they want to get
- again and then eventually gonna be DQ
is it subject to interpretation whether
a guy is stalling or their guy is just
if they're cancelling each other out I'm
sorry if is it subject to interpretation
whether it's stalling or whether or not
they're cancelling each other out like
one guy's trying to advance the other
guy's stopping them at for advance
they're just both looking for the
opening yeah but you can see easily who
is wants to progress and who is once you
just control the position for this guy
who don't want to progress he will be I
mean you can order I mean in theory
maybes but if you see it you can see who
is just trying to minimize the action
and try to wait for their opportunity
and though the one who's tried to make
it happen you know what about submission
only tournament stilettos the Federation
also have this kind of rule we have two
sets of rules the point rules system for
tournaments and we have the challenge
rules for can be even tournament but for
match for matchmaking like the metamoris
kind or or any promoter who will try to
do something like the baddest the
baddest purple belt so is no way
division is no time limit he can
approach that the time as he wish like
okay that will be 20 minutes match will
be 15 minutes match will be half-hour
match when you think about Gracie worlds
and Gracie Nationals they it's all
submission only yeah after 15 minutes if
there's no sub submission
they're both disqualified yeah I I just
agree with that that me that
disqualification I spoke with hoes and
she maybe I mean we wanna get into the
batter for the jujitsu but for me it's
the same rules in case of a bracket so I
don't feel like both who kind of didn't
submit suppose should be disqualified
because sometimes in the same bracket
two tough guys they fight each other and
they could not submit to each other and
then some too I mean halfway Buster's
yes they want submit the other so this
guy advances and those two are
disqualified so I don't think this is
fair somebody has to come in from this
so the way I did is the first round goes
full force and if the 20 minutes the end
or 30 minutes the end depends off the
arrangement after the 10 minutes you ask
the guy you want to fight the guys say
yes and then you ask the guy you want to
fight yes so is another round so in the
second round we still don't have
positive points but every time the guy
put himself in a position and he started
defending himself without attempting to
escape or giving the combat just
protecting or resting or whatever the
refere you gonna say hey man keep going
acting or you going to be penalized so
we have negative points for diminishing
of combativity so at the end of the
second round if we see like somebody
with minus points this one will be the
loser you know because he display last
desire or less gas or less techniques to
be on top of the the competition so his
mind was because he's defending all the
time he was tired or whatever so he gets
- points and then the other guy advances
for the the bracket so that's the only
change for the submission are you
familiar with my have a submission only
tournament as well I don't know if
you're aware of that
and it's very similar to Gracie world's
crazy Nationals but the both at
15-minute matches but both competitors
aren't disqualified we actually have an
overtime
around and in there and the overtime
it's kind of like soccer I didn't want
over times to be determined by wrestling
and a lot of tournaments it's like you
go into overtime and and whoever's the
best wrestler wins because you get the
takedown and then they hold and they win
so a lot of wrestlers can go into
tournaments and go I'm just gonna stall
for regulation taken in overtime and win
with my wrestling so in order to
eliminate that I wanted to know who the
best submission artist is not who the
best wrestler is so my overtime each
person we went into overtime you get to
start on my back with the leg hooks and
an over-under and then we go
if you submit me then I get to go on
your back and if you escape you win but
if I submit you then we go another round
it's just it's like extra innings and
then the next round you take my back I
escape
I take your back and I submit you I win
that's in a dreamland of course but we
that way we get to find out who the best
is that submitting we couldn't finish in
regulation now we go into overtime and
we start on each other's backs like free
kicks yeah but I think I think this is a
valid but you take the element of calm
conquer the position I think the fight
has should be even standing up if the
wrestlers start to avoiding or if they
any avoiding of combativity supposed to
be penalized but I love you could fake
that though like a wrestler could take
it I take shot yeah one thing is for
sure in this new Federation in the same
way we have the master council we're
gonna have the Development Council and
you're gonna be invited right now to be
part because I see people like you guys
are not just know the deal know that
this sport but also has opinion to make
and my idea is not ride my rules and
stone my idea is to follow the best
bedroom to create more effectiveness and
more dynamic aspect for the sport so the
Federation has this open heart and open
eye and open years to kind of make the
best conclusions for the sport so all
the rules can be changed everything can
be adapted to a better more define this
play of effectiveness that's a beautiful
thing when will this go into effect and
when will your first Ouija no no I'm not
playing only in events my idea is to
serve a service so I gonna service
through the information I'm gonna
service to giving reference and giving
guidance for the events but even though
they don't do my rules I will legitimize
everybody and I will start to relate the
records of every event who won here who
won there and I start to putting
everybody to become part of the same
profile the same mindset and I will
hammer the idea of why we don't do the
best rules for jiu-jitsu because I bet
the champions today many of them they're
gonna say I don't like I prefer to this
or that but I'm not here to educate
those champions I'm here to educate 85%
of the competitive community today who
is still white and blue belt those guys
they being misled to understand the
strategy of the game to get the medals
but they're losing effectiveness in real
life so the change of rules aside of the
education aspect of the Federation is
very important how I see the service of
the Federation in the educational level
because a lot of times guys coming from
the comparative background and they from
white to purple to maroon and black so
they become tough competitors sometimes
champions they become famous then they
open the school and as they open the
school they teach what they know their
techniques who make them few champions
so great but this is just like a
percentage of what he's supposed to know
to teach because nay not everybody wants
to dare go there to compete not
everybody has the skills and the
toughness to engage in that kind of
level of training I feel like jiu-jitsu
is there to favor the community as a
whole
I feel like this structure he has to be
knowledgeable about
self-defense about self-defense for
women about programs for kids kids class
in law enforcement so as this structure
becomes certified I mean I'm not a gonna
validate all the to audit the
instructors all the black belts today
I'm not gonna say you don't deserve it
but I will suggest to them to get
certified through the Federation because
they will get elements for their schools
become more efficient retain more
students have a better teaching programs
which are the core of effectiveness the
other day I heard some black belts being
asked for a student about self defense
hey teacher you teacher said no no if
you want a self-defense you go to grab
my gun
you know and I felt that this is just
something which goes straight on my
heart because for me the core of jujitsu
is self-defense if you don't know
self-defense basically you don't know
jiu-jitsu you have to be ready to choose
to defend yourself from a slapping from
a hug from a headlock from whatever and
if you don't have those concepts line up
you become sometimes very tough with
tough years with very good grip and
Durin's forever but you're still
counting on your own physicality you
still continue you cannot teach that for
a children or for a women so by having
the Federation presenting those courses
and expressing this all over the world
the teacher will have much more elements
to have more students to feed the the
more knowledge to feed you know the his
students in different levels and and
make a different job with Fugit so you
know so this is beautiful so your
motivation is just to improve jiu-jitsu
yes you see a bad direction that it's
going shoots is losing effectiveness and
we have to restore that buy-in for me
very well by understand the competition
as a progressive thing to make you
better fighter not to make a better
competitor you know if your competitor
sometimes a Taekwondo guy he's a great
competitor but has nothing to do it for
your life
I mean you want to be a fighter
jiu-jitsu is something you learn to
protect your honor to protect your
dignity to represent to fight to make
money in the cage whatever your goals
are jiu-jitsu is there to support you in
a very profound and deep cause which is
affect effectiveness the transition
between jiu-jitsu and jiu-jitsu
competition and mixed martial arts is a
very tricky transition for a lot of
jiu-jitsu fighters yes especially when
they don't have that kind of strong
background you know I think if everybody
fights like Krong we don't have to set
up rules because he wants to accelerate
he was he wants to be progressive you
know he's not once won by points he
wants to go to the queue so a guys like
him or Boucher or some other great
athletes they go and they choose to
fight openly you know to see some other
fights they choose the strategy is
strategic elements to just give them
more chances just points just point just
advantage sometimes 10 minutes fight
then nothing happens just to advantage
that's terrible I mean I don't expect to
see this in a fight and nobody expects
so by changing rules we increase the
effectiveness we create a more dynamic
fight is more interesting to see you
know nobody wants to see something
boring and we create under this concept
the possibility to unify the whole
community not only this particular
Association or this Federation but
everybody in the same pot and then
without taking anything from nobody my
vision is to create a worldwide circuit
of jiu-jitsu which represents the same
tank they are a SP for sir for the ATT
for tennis which brings major players
like big sponsors and and intellivision
for the sport so first is unified try to
unify the rules try to create effective
and try to give a better condition for
the teacher for the school honor for the
independent promoter because I cannot
thinking about okay I gonna start to
make my own circus and I don't validate
nobody it's just me like other people do
so that's a wrong way to unified and
educate the community in our culture for
the future Kron said publicly that he
feels a part of the problem the Starling
problem is the holding of the sleeves do
you think is there pasta I that's what I
think too I totally agree with him I
think the fact that you have to have
your sleeves you can't have your sleeve
tight because then your opponent can't
grab it I think that is so backwards I
think that it should be illegal to grab
the sleeve illegal I think it should be
illegal I think I think is possible it
should be legal what is in what is
unacceptable is that grip promotes
there's only a cool-off situation I can
grab anywhere I want if my intention is
to progress yeah if I start to say ok
coming to me coming to Papa and I stay
here waiting to waste your energy and
then when you make a mistake I sweep you
that's kind of weak weaken your mindset
weaken your progressiveness weaken your
effectiveness so what if he's stuck
there like he has asleep and he stuck
because he's trying to pass and if he
lets go the sleeve then you're gonna
pass and you're kind of just stuck there
and you're like I can't let go of the
sleeve because let it go man let it go
and go for the risk don't you think that
cause problems with the ref and the refs
interpretation of what's darling
whatever is holding if you're not moving
is a stalling so you should have the MU
hip movement and the angles and the
booty fast on the knees whenever you do
because if the guy don't make a complete
pass he's still like I almost no
advantage yeah so it's just keep going
do you think it's less of an issue with
nogi the song East all is less because
you know gear you can stall in 50 50s
and different things will be easier but
you have much less elements to submit I
feel like the noogie is just take maybe
70% of the submission options still some
classic ones but not that many so I feel
like it's just
last options but it's still the same
exactly the same fight when you did the
Budo challenge we went to see that it
was a great great event yes but what has
changed since your your ideas when you
put that on - today my ideas are the
same Buddha challenge is a great rule
for I stream event for a prime
television event it's not a sport
competition event because aim is the
submission and only pros competing and
it's like a premium sensational thing
which has no time for stalling it's all
pushing forward so the whole pressure I
think is almost that but in big
tournaments has to be a little more
sportive we have to have points you have
to have a time limit which is a
quarterly to the the belt and so but
it's the idea of the concept a
progressive concept of going to the
submission helps you be embrace I mean
has to be in the whole mindset for every
fighter you know it's not doesn't change
that the way you fight has to be focus
on the submit the guy to be the best the
best one out there
when is your first big tournament are
you planning on having a big world like
I want to have like you know October the
first event but I already have for
example next week and the second and
third the Volcan open they will apply
the new rules and it's all testing we're
gonna test the rules to see because the
idea is a positive beneficial idea for
the sport and if we need to adjust a
little more and change like I said is
nothing is on the stone yet and we're
gonna allow the think chew of you know
hearing people and seeing the
conclusions because the mission is very
positive and the means will be adaptable
that's a beautiful thing yes yeah it is
a beautiful thing I'm very happy you've
seen jiu-jitsu progress from the time
you were a boy to what it is today
I mean it's gotta be an amazing thing an
amazing thing also to have taken part in
those first initial invasion moments
when you guys came and you liked this so
many of the Gracie in action videos
where you know Horan is battling with
the karate guys and you know you
battling with you duel guys and people
that had no idea what you Jitsu was yes
I remember very clearly when I saw the
first Ultimate Fighting Championship
that I saw was number two they had a
videotape that was out and I watched it
and I watched hoist win and I remember
thinking myself man I didn't even know
that there was anything like this out
there I had no idea I had been martial
arts my whole life yeah I had no idea
that someone could do something like I
was doing karate and man when I watched
UFC two first because UFC 1 they didn't
have any highlights to show cause well
they didn't release it their idea was
they were gonna release two first and
then they were gonna release one for
some reason nobody UFC one was they did
have pay-per-view for UFC one yeah but
it wasn't available in VHS yes
and then so once I heard that UFC one
was real my friend said hey that because
I saw pre before and I thought oh that's
fake that's like WWF that's not real so
I ignored it and then my friend came
home one day my roommate said hey
ultimate challenge thing it's real some
guy Guitar Center told me it was really
said some some Iranian guy was just
choking people out he would just grab
him by the throat he said I ran more
essence but he spit the tooth like in
there my friend the guy who told me
didn't see it he heard it second and so
he said yes I'm Iranian apparently was
grabbing people by the throat and
choking everybody huh I said some
Iranian I go dude dude he didn't fight I
was doing karate for six months I go it
wasn't a karate guy was it because yeah
he beat karate beatboxes he'd be like oh
by choking him out like this he goes
yeah that's what they told me and I go
so that second one came out my friend
called up goes the ultimate challenge
thing is coming out again I go tape it
tape it so I got home and I watched it
and man I hated hoist Gracie and cuz I
won the karate guy to win when he fought
my nokia char I'm like that was my hero
I didn't even who he was but he did
karate and I thought okay zero and then
but on the other side was Pat Smith and
I didn't like him and and I didn't like
hoist either but then by the time the
finals came I fell in love with hoist
boys by the time the finals hit I was in
love with him and I go I gotta find this
because I wrestled in high school a
couple years and I thought either this
is primitive wrestling or it's super
advanced wrestling I didn't know what it
was so I went in found John
Jacques Machado I went in there and I
got choked out 37 times my purple belt
by a Dave Meyer Dave never do and I
remember thinking one day I'm gonna be
able to do this with someone who just
walked in i was so from that point on I
was obsessed this is like a changing
life experience yes what was it like for
you to be there too did not compete and
knowing that you were better than your
brother if there's all this talk about
why you didn't compete I come here to
support hardian and and the cause of
being like spreading the art and one
point I was hardened soldiers choo choo
for whatever and and in another point I
decided to to follow my own path and and
of course keeping keeping the Alliance
but going in my own direction and then
harden called me and asked me to train
hoist I didn't know why and he said and
then he said oh I planning should do
some event I said okay let's do it
so I was his coach for the first and
second event and then somebody asked me
through Eric Paulson and assistant of
daniel-san to Yuri Nakamura yes sure yes
so he sent me invitation to participate
of a church a short tomp competition so
and then they sent me a tape to see what
the rules are about and I didn't like
the rules but I liked the locks so I
start training the locks when I said no
man this is my means no I don't like it
so and then we start to immediately I
say I don't want to do and then my
ex-wife much more calm start to
negotiate with the guys and start to say
but if we change the rules so was the
kind of talk and talk and eventually
they decide to change the rules for a
new open rules like and then I advise
the way supposed to be the rules so we
create the new night value to the 94 and
then when I sign the mean when I about
to sign the contract hard and call me
I said Hickson why are you doing said
yeah man I'd be invited to fight in
Japan said no you should not go because
this goes against the family UFC is our
game we should be in support the family
and stay here as hi scotch I said man
that's not exactly what I vision for
myself because I mean I'm here being
coach I get one penny you you put a lot
of dollars in your pocket you give me
nothing I mean you give me some money
for me to sit on the bench we are in
business but if you give me enough and
the guys offered me a lot of money to go
you don't even have it you gave me what
did they offer you just got me to give
me some said now now you should do for
the love of difference I am and I love
you guys but you love me and you give me
enough and how I gonna love you I mean
so I went to Japan and deal in my tank
and statue winning there and and then I
get my my direction towards Japan which
was very good for me you know the
community there the education the
culture there was was very I mean I feel
like home and that's pretty much where I
direct myself my career my end of my
career to Japan and but now cronies back
to see what's gonna happen so were you
worried at all with hoist doing the UFC
did you did you think cuz he was the
youngest one of the brothers riding
he didn't compete as much in like were
you worried at all that maybe it was yes
but the idea of the primary idea of
hoisin going in is because he was not
the best one but he was something he's
gonna be a good test for him is a good
you know to break the ice and stuff but
but not exactly if something happened is
always a backup you were the backup yes
so I was there to just jump in in case
so someone beat hoist you would have
jumped into the chemo incident yeah yeah
after that that was already engaging
Japan as a racially yes I you had a
contract with them over there yeah not
not for many fights I never did many
fights contract I mean many fights in
one contract but I felt like hard and
create a very awkward situation you know
and
was a kind of little did division you
know so I was not appealing to go there
and show my support to hoist and be
there just so I allowed him to have his
own destiny and it was also the talk
that hoist was a slender guy who was
younger he wasn't as intimidating as you
and that it it sort of accentuated the
idea of jujitsu they did to his
technique base where's your you're a
scary guy you're scary guy now but you
were really scary guy then you were the
only yoked shred like 185 right
something like that yeah yeah I start
Zulu was like I have 74 kilos with 74
kilos of maybe 180 180 okay maybe maybe
a little less and then my my last fight
in Japan I did with Hunan Funaki yes I
was 195 nice yes he was like 220 right
yeah Aki for Nagas 230 should tell you
something and then you know I was making
a preparation to go heavier than this
sometimes even 200 and then Korea cut
down for the to get my best shape when
we spoke it was 2000 and when we had
dinner was it 2005 or something like
that somewhere around there sure yes you
were still thinking about fighting yes a
door oh yeah higher level guys yes yes
but not I never materialised though
never yes because I never have the after
my my son departure on 2000 I was about
to make the best contract of my life was
I just finished with Funaki and I
receive a proposal a Mira Nair proposed
which you fight Sakuraba he was still on
the top and then my son departure I have
to have like a moment for the family and
regroup as a whole by departure your son
passed away yes so was a moment I could
I could escape by doing a fight say okay
I gonna focus on the fight but I felt
like my family will be completely
unprotected and unsupported so I said no
done I don't care about the fight I will
be so I spent about two years to
to make the whole family feels good
again and we all regain strength and
happiness again so after that I started
to to get another get a free agent for a
couple of years we try to make something
close to what I have but they did the
whole business in itself in Japan the
fact sakuraba loss for Wanderlei and
things like that diminish that kind of
huge purse and then I felt like no I
just want to fight if is if it's that
much so I started to be very resistance
about my next fight some opportunites
but I kind of push away and to the point
on 2008 I was already moved back to
Brazil for a while a guy from Texas
invited me to compete in a new event and
put me to fight feather and I was
looking for that but I was I have a
little injury on my hip and until I be
able to feel good to training I could
not sign and because it has a deadline
in terms of promotion and such I could
not sign without having a hundred
percent confidence because if I sign I
will fight I'm not gonna and I feel
don't have the time I wanna get so I
said you know what I don't want it and
in my heart I went to the beach and said
thank you God for everything I have I'm
out so I stopped competing not exactly
the way I want but I felt like I have to
respect God's decision and I just don't
wanna just jeopardizing my life for the
money you know for okay the guy put me
money I go there and so I feel like I
have to go to representative shit so
either I go 100 percent or you know I
hope somebody else coming and then I'll
let see what grown does all the great
fighters that you saw during that time
from the time well hoist entered the UFC
till the time that you retired the guys
like Mark Coleman and bas Rutten phaidor
and what were there any that you really
wish that you could have had an
opportunity to match up against
I always visualizing myself against the
number one you know I could not even
think about
so one point it was Coleman the other
point was you know I mean you name it
the champions and then Fedor get the
risin that makes it like a big
expression so I could not thinking about
other guy to represent jiu-jitsu you
know I have always true vision that but
the set of rules are different you know
at the time we could express technique
with more because we had time you know I
never somebody asked me oh yeah you have
only few fights in MMA I said no I never
fought MMA I always fought valley to do
because MMA is a different animal you go
there for three rounds five minutes it's
better to have offensive techniques than
defensive techniques the defense not
gonna do good for you
it's gonna do good if you have at least
one round ten minutes and then another
so if you have like my fights or ours
endless rounds of 50 minutes these
endless rounds of five minutes so and
that way you can prepare yourself for a
different strategy you know you have to
follow the movements and you cannot just
go all the way if stamped your gas and
then fill up in empty again because you
know if you emptier gas in the wrong
time you're in trouble so all the
technique and stretching your gas and be
calm and finding comfortable positions
those are strip right now now it becomes
a very stream very physical you see
athletes in the same way division but a
guy who fights in the 155 walks around
with 180 185 you know so the technology
on the sport today is a huge thing the
physicality
that's why taking techniques is only a
piece of it you know what chrome does
today is not only training jiu-jitsu and
become comfortable in the skills he
training like a dog and all the elements
he can do to become a cleric and
explosive in physical I'm gonna lost
weight like everybody else plus the
technique which I feel and one point
will be the edge he needs to to make the
difference so do you think there's
something missing in today's mixed
martial arts that the
the original jujitsu sort of expressed
this this idea of having an open round
having a No Limit fight is is there a
room for that today do you think do you
think we're we're hampered by this idea
of a three hour pay-per-view window or
to our television window it's funny
because you know the other day I get
caught watching a four hour match in
tennis you know what's a great match was
alone and if you go in one more service
oh man you see I have no idea that long
go that long do you Povich in my dau and
if I think French Open last year I was
five hours five hours five hours
non-stop man and the tiebreak and start
again and the advantage was unbelievable
you know so if you're passionate about
tennis sometimes the game can be like 45
minutes sometimes can be a couple of
hours because you dare in the action you
know so for me when we talking about
engagement we're talking about I mean
the best one out there
and when I see a fight after 15 minutes
because somebody punch once or fall on
top or just given a true both guys stand
up they both decide and then the time is
over who wants the fight in my opinion
supposed to be a draw because how the
guy can can win just because one more
point the guys are warriors the guys are
willing to go so it's always like
halfway to what supposed to be you know
because okay you have to decide by
points after field okay so I mean it's
hard because you know sometimes like I
even have the best of it but that
doesn't guarantee if the fight goes
longer if you still that because
toughness resilience and in heart and
technique they all wanna pay in one
point gonna pay a big a big situation
you know so is for me not did you the
rules today and you have seen such
doesn't translate the best guy out there
translates the most agile the most tough
the one who get connect first you know
because sometimes the fight can be
either way
the whoever connects first whoever makes
the food can win so it's kind of hard to
evaluate but if you put two guys in the
cage and okay man whoever's get out
first is the winner so and that's a
different animal because you have to be
technical you have to be patient you
have Chubby's so you know I can see
first is their expectations all in the
how Crone gonna do
but if confirms where I believe can be
done eventually I feel like chrome will
be comfortable to challenge anyone for a
no time limit fight because I mean I
don't care if he's Velasquez I don't
care if his John John's if Chrome do
what he has to do with the time he has
to do I believe on him like I believe
myself if I have the help today and the
physicality I so I like to have I mean I
don't see a guy just because he's
winning on the cage he can win me
because I don't see the opportunites
happen on the cage I'm not gonna give
those opportunities so it's hard to say
but you know the weight division doesn't
make too much difference for me if I
have the time to cook and slow burn but
if the things kind of if even in my
weight division 80 kilos for example if
I wanna fight that guy we have 95 kilos
and make a technology so I gonna fight a
different monster in five minutes rounds
is almost impossible Howie I mean so and
then that's kind of unbalanced now based
on the stream aspect of the sport the
physicality of the sport and the
technique who has to be applied so the
difference between a fight and a match
the difference between a fight and sport
and in a fight they're just two guys
going at each other and I agree that
there's many many many fights where a
guy will win a 10-9 round and another
guy won the other 10 right now and then
one guy win the final round maybe just
for a little roll or some it's a draw
it's not done it's like sex without an
orgasm it's not complete yes and
normally happens I mean sometimes
beautiful knockouts but sometimes you
know it's just you know a too much
strength
too much physicality and every time goes
to the flooding I immediately stand up
because if he knows if he's to stay on
the ground
he's losing time and he's not gonna be
able to capitalize because the time is
not as long as enough and to so that's
kind of you know a great area is it's
not it doesn't have the appeal for me to
see a good a good match what about one
who is fought Sakuraba and they had that
crazy 90 minute match yes what about
that was a an idea of like having these
long long matches for hours in jiu-jitsu
we need time because we don't have I
mean we give the advantage of wait we
give advantage of you know whatever so
let's at least have the time for us to
be become strategical would you have
preferred that kind of a fight to be no
rounds though because that fight they
broke up into a series of rounds yeah I
mean at that point I felt like was a
lack of action of I mean hoist supposed
to fight better I was not on his side
and I see a pattern on him to sometimes
make little mistakes which when I was
there I was focused on making him few
sharp and if I'm not there I felt like a
little fuzzy attitude mentally his focus
was not so it's a lot of different
elements for Chuchu Chuchu Chuchu
justified you know because I believe
Weiss has elements to beat Sakuraba
you know and but he didn't so it's just
you get the second time yeah every match
yeah I found second time in LA right was
yeah yeah
were you there when he fought him the
second time match did you know he beat
him right yeah and this is the rematch
you know what you were aware of that
right no I'm not oh okay yeah they had a
rematch and he beat him here in LA won
right it was k1 it was it the Colosseum
yeah that was the first time Brock
Lesnar fought - yeah now there's a lot
of problems jiu-jitsu guys have
world-class mundial black belt champions
have in MMA is they get in the cage and
it happens I would say it's a big reason
why they end up getting cut from the UFC
is they
not fighting wrestlers like everyone at
the top ten is really hard to take down
in the UFC yes
so jiu-jitsu guy will come in and he's
fighting a guy who wrestled his whole
life there's zero chance that he's gonna
be able to take down that wrestler so
he's forced to kickbox right so the
wrestlers forcing the kick box
kickboxing fight because the jiu-jitsu
guy can't take down the wrestler in in
those situations um like I don't know if
you remember Nogueira
when he fought tim sylvia the big giant
guy he could not take tim sylvia down so
he eventually shot tim sylvia sprawled a
little bit and the Nogueira pulled guard
he was on his back he swept him he got
on top and then he choked him out with a
guillotine yes so in that situation the
guard pool saved Nogueira like as what
do you think about a hundred percent
100% confident in the guard because what
I see today in the display of great
jiu-jitsu fighters in the cage is they
have the guard but they have a sportive
guard they don't have a valid to do
guard yes they not dangerous from the
bottom yes so they become technicals
from the bottom against the dangerous
ground in pound
yeah so they get all that they're
getting all that disadvantage so in my
perspective for example Kron
he's been training to deal with tough
wrestlers tough boxers but he don't try
to apply wrestling against wrestling
because he's gonna need another life to
become like a chutes or like Matt Hughes
or like some other tough what is the
strategy for Kron when he fights a
wrestler that he can't take down he
brings to the guard so he's a guard is
something that he's talking about guard
is no other option on the ground Jiu
Jitsu has to be happy on top and happier
on the bottom yes people frown upon I'm
a big advocate of pulling garden and I
made their fighters that have done it
there's a guy named Paul sass from
England he pulls guard all the time he's
a master of pulling guard he knows
exactly how to do it he shoots deep the
guy sprawls and as he sprawling he pulls
guard and he puts people in triangles
base yeah yeah but yeah he but but the
triangle is risky because once you know
how to defend like
lock you becoming available for grant
ground-and-pound so if the guy is
completely safe on the not getting
caught in the triangle your attempts of
techniques are kind of diminishing your
capacity to survive and to defend
yourself so you are attacking techniques
from the bottom but you still on the
ridge yes so the idea of a perfect value
to the guard is save your distance -
don't get pounded by those surprising
key elbows like don't challenge over oh
no no you cannot clinch you have to use
the legs and you have to heat with the
legs so it's always a striking from the
bottom you know doesn't have some
beautiful so you don't believe that you
should be quenched and only if the guy
if the guy promotes that if he wants
this pace to hit you you need to be
comfortable and hit him back so it's a
fight where Imagi 12 year old kid laying
down on the ground with fits to you if
you start using the foot it's going to
be hard for even you with a big man to
reach yeah so it's no use of the legs
people has no clue how to striking how
to use I know in UFC has some illegal
heel from the bar yeah but you still can
use different strikes you know you can
even have the distance to serve I hope
to be completely protected against
elbows and and the issue though that if
someone can disengage if you're on your
back and you're trying to not clinch and
not hold on to them your jiu-jitsu
practitioner the guy can just disengage
you have made they just stand up once it
is engaged he's escaping from the fight
I can stand up again and then and keep
the same process of clinching so so now
Crone's in a situation where he's
fighting a wrestler and he can't take
him down then he pulls guard yeah and
then he opens up his legs to kick the
guy stands up now he's got to stand up
again yes so they could just keep doing
that over and over again and if it's a
wrestler like how does he want Chuck
Liddell who's an expert striker as well
as a wrestler very tough to take down
but also an expert striker yeah when you
get that guy to the ground don't you
want to optimize that opportunity as
much as possible and hang on to them
while you're on the bottom
that's depends depends where the weight
division where what is the weight
distribution is I have to obey this
sense
if he's on me I will sweep him I will be
on his back in no time if he's away from
me if he wants to looking for distance I
have to understand that and respect that
and protect myself to don't get pounded
you know and in that process of okay I
don't wanna engage he's moving back and
then you stand up and all this process a
lot of things happen what is important
for a jiu-jitsu fighter is know
everything about the anti game of the
striker
I don't make Kron I don't try to make
Kron a good striker I want to make him
comfortable to in and out I want to make
very comfortable to fight inside with
knees and elbows you know this be
dangerous inside be comfortable on top
and be very comfortable on the bottom in
the action and because it's a lot of
even though I know those five minutes
fight is a lot of action I mean it's a
lot of stalling is a lot of studying is
a lot of disengage I mean they engage a
little B and then they separate and okay
now let's think let's see who's fight
it's hard to see a guy who's just goes
like and I feel like the great element
the greatest strategy of chrome is gonna
keep a consistent pressure that means
he's not gonna be studying or in a
distance where the striker feels like
waiting is gonna be there chew out or
chew in and then once is in let's fight
in fight let's fight like you know
elbows wherever and then immediately the
fight goes to the ground no matter if
he's one on top or on the bottom and
then the consistence of this I feel like
opportunities will rise do you watch MMA
a lot yes did you watch BJ Penn's last
fight yes that fight was very sad to me
very sad to watch you know I was very
frustrated watching it as a BJ Penn fan
as a Frankie Edgar fan I thought it was
a great performance
but what one of the things that
frustrates me about BJ is that he very
rarely attacks from his back when he's
on the bottom
he puts feet on the hips and he just
kind of holds on yes maybe he was not as
that
Klee I don't know I mean he did the poor
a poor a poor game from the bottom in my
perspective he's supposed to have a
little more elements to should not
preserve his integrity but also to
attack you know and I don't feel that
and I feel like I mean he's just not
doing what he's supposed to Eddie we
talked about that yeah that sort of
frustrated you a little bit too right
yes I don't know if you're aware of this
section but I'm I'm obsessed with I've
been obsessed with developing the best
guard for when they're striking I
analyze it and to death and the guard
that I comprised they put elements from
you know my students help me Nina
Schembri helped me so I put all these
elements together but it all started off
when I was on this quest to put together
the ultimate guard for MMA cuz I was
seeing too many guys just get beat up in
the guard and I thought we got a like I
felt like you have like the
effectiveness is gone what is the
problem why are people getting pounded
in the guard we have to change this so
the first thing I studied was you and
Enzo this was back in the 90s I go okay
well I'm gonna I'm gonna attempt to
improve the guard in MMA so I looked at
you and I looked at him Django what are
they doing they're in full guard and
they're holding the over hook to prevent
the punch like anybody try to punch in
the guard with their right arm you would
over hook it and when headbutts were
legal your your left hand was like this
you were like this protecting the
headbutt but then when they man had a
head butts legal you don't have to do
this no more so you could hold the head
now and now in this position with the
overlook you have full guard you're
holding the head there's a clinch there
so to me as trying to be a jujitsu
scientist trying I'm like if that that
is the stance in MMA that's it you and
him so that's what you guys are doing it
you look at all the old fights full
guard stop the punch hold the head and
so to me that was the starting point yes
I agree and but Jiu Jitsu is an animal
who's never stopped to grow yes you know
and one day I was comfortably in
California watching a fight in Brazil
and then I saw like I hate men
tournament
fabulou gel was fighting mark care and
my care was the first time he'd show up
in the and the first time I saw him
fighting that was his first tournament
means yeah so when he went to the finals
with Fabio and I knew fab you like train
with him he's a brother you know we and
I saw why he did with Fabio like stay on
thought ground-and-pound and smashing
the elbe on his face absolutely fabulous
tooth getting to his arm and it's like
next day you saw inflamed arm and you go
into the airplane like this he made
almost lose the arm because then they
give vent about ever but anyway after I
saw that fight and they in the lack of
options fabulous there next day in the
morning I wake up I call my son Hawks on
his ten to eleven years old about 110
pounds said Hawks will come here and
then I went to the garage on my mats
it's a lay down put him lay down and I
try to represent the same position
because they did they differ the size
weight is almost the same from father
goes out to marker than me for hawksin
so I kind of immediately put him in the
fabulous position and I put myself in in
a marker position and then I start to
analyze his pose instead Croxon do this
do that move a little more this way so
was not we're not a fighting but I try
to find him a position for him it should
be comfortable and I spend about 45 and
50 minutes searching studying with him
because I like that kind of
unproportional sighs mm-hmm when I
finish that that section I'm totally
like III reinvent myself in terms of
what I gonna do if I have to fight
Marquette tomorrow because I was
satisfied with the angles I could put
hawksin in order to resist my leverage
my angles what you exactly I saw in the
day before so that means from one day to
another I kind of focus myself and fix
it a problem I saw with Fabio
and at that point I felt like okay I'm
fixed now I'm ready to fight funny
without you model and what is this what
is this stance what did you change a
little I could not I could not have him
oxen could not have mean control he has
to create distance he has true how Shen
across the belly no he has to use defeat
more properly on the hips yes he has to
use the knee on the chest sometimes he
has to use the element of of as I
approach to getting better position the
bottom guy has to hit because if you
don't strike you don't make the guy kind
of go back so it's a combination between
fighting in Brazil we have two different
names when you bro and when you fight
fight is more like a sportive and when
you bro you like just do it
whatever so technically speaking when
somebody wants to attack me as a brawler
I don't want to fight a broad back I
want to be technical and survive and be
comfortable and suns that to say for I
cannot have anything here let me be
backing coach you see if I can advance
and that's the time I will blow against
him and make him get confused so I have
to change strategies as he come if you
come it should be a fighter I will be
aggressive I will be mean if he come it
should be a brawler I will be technical
and I will be comfortable so that kind
of sense of change gives a perspective
for the bottom guy should be on on edge
which would be on top of the offense now
mark her in that fight that you're
talking about Fabio show headbutts
really go so that was a huge part of how
he was getting busted up with head butts
but since then head butts are becoming
legal were the head butts a big reason
you decided to change your guard stance
also but the elbows in the reach and the
way the guy positioned himself you know
and the way Fabio was always with the
leg cross he was falling exactly what he
learned and what he saw and he he could
not have the time to improvise nobody
expect mark Kerr being tough as he was
and ceramic the monsters just happened
in front of fabula and he has to deal
with whatever he did you know he was
crying and throwing up in the locker
room before that fire yeah he was very
emotional yes very nervous and I mean
shows him a little documentary he did he
always had violence but I mean in one
point he's a potential he was the man to
be beaten he was like he was enormous
yes and you know as a fan as a fan of
jujitsu and a fan of mixed martial arts
and volley to them I just wish you had
had those opportunities to face those
guys I would have loved to have seen
that nature now I'm what i en't like I
said I just when I was trying to figure
out the best MMA guard I was looking at
you I was looking at Hicks and grabbing
the over ugh and but the one thing I
knew is if that's the defensive posture
this is what I was thinking I didn't
know you changed it up but at that point
I thought that was it that's the
defensive posture someone was in your
guard you have to defend first so I
thought well okay that has to be the
stance so we have to create offense from
that stance so the defense is first and
do we have offense from the oberg and my
instructor Jean Jacques Machado he is
one of the only guys I know of out of
all the top two Jitsu guys that his
whole game is based on the over hook and
not grabbing the sleeves because his
left hand he was born without fingers so
no matter what whether it was gay or
noogie he needed that over hook because
he couldn't control the sleeves so his
over hook game was translated to his
students me included so I was always
looking for the over because Jean
Jacques was my master and and then one
when he got invited to Abu Dhabi before
he went to Abu Dhabi there was a lot of
legends there there were a lot of
jiu-jitsu legends that were going to abu
dhabi and without the key there was no
offense there was a lot of boring
matches but jean jacques shows up and he
just rises above everybody if you watch
what Jean Jacques did in Abu Dhabi he
didn't change his left arm didn't change
without it gears like no key I'm still
gonna grab that over hook anyways
everybody else was lost because they
were used to their fighting stance their
guard fighting stance was sleeve call
her call her sleeve
so without the Gita had to change
everything and they weren't
to it they didn't have any offense from
their so to me I took what what you and
hen zou were doing with the Overlook and
the controlling but that's how John John
fights with the over hook so all his
sweeps on John suitors look at all the
sweeps in Abu Dhabi's throwing people
around his first year he submitted
everybody he was like the first marcelo
garcia everybody was freaked out like
how is this guy doing it they they they
didn't even understand it but to me it
was like it's because his game didn't
change when he's training in the EE he's
trained for Abu Dhabi the the people
that were training in the key before
they weren't trained for Abu Dhabi he
was because it was all over look every
was sweeping wrestlers all the qaul'
know he was all over these guys so for
me that overhook not is not for
jean-jacques that overhook is important
for grappling not even for volley to dos
so if he did violet judo or someone with
that style guard did violet Tudor the
over hook game automatically takes away
the punch and he has offense from that
style too so for me that became the the
the basis and the focus for the ultimate
MMA guard was to master the over hook
like like Jean Jacques and not only just
defend but put those butterflies in and
try to sweep or set up triangles like
you you have an overlook you sweep he
bases you grab that wrist boom triangle
so I thought that was the based on what
you and him so did and Jean Jacques
style because because of it's like a
blessing in disguise him boring born
without fingers it is it was a blessing
in disguise he's an Abu Dhabi legend
everybody looks at Jean Jacques Yoda
like how did you come in to Abu Dhabi
and finish everybody to me it was just
that overhook game he didn't really have
to change much of his game so that's how
marcelo garcia that's his philosophy -
his philosophy is and he said this an
interview said if you can't do it if
you're training if there's Aggie
technique that you can't do noogie throw
it out only focus on the techniques that
are gonna translate to noogie so that
way when you're practicing the ghee
you're actually practicing noogie as
well
so Jean John Orr Marcelo is very against
being reliant too much on the collar and
too much on the sleeve he stays away
from that because even takedowns he
doesn't want to do judo takedowns
because
nogi they're not gonna work as much he
wants to do take down that in the ghee
that translate noogie
so I'm now that's just this the
conclusions that I came to that's how I
trained my fighters that are fighting an
MMA and it all started with watching you
and hens oh yes I I completely you know
feel like that's a good standard
position too because you have to have a
control and stuff but the evolutionary
process brought order to kind of the
guards you know and I can also find my
my comfort about those days and and just
and show and a more space regard the
more like towards my father's guard was
because he was very weak guy always
handle big guys and he don't have like
this kind of strength or or control over
Europe over his opponents so he was more
like hip movements and using the the
ankles using the foot you know it's more
like a very little from the bottom
allowing the guy to get lost so it's a
combination between the two I think his
two days is the perfect option why do
you think Ronda Rousey is the only
fighter in MMA today that when she she's
pulling off her arm bar looks amazing
have you seen her it's why is as soon as
she's in the garden she's not gonna wait
she's gonna go and attack that arm and
she goes right to it she doesn't wait
and I've trained with her many times and
her arm bar is legit it's it's not a
joke it's yeah to me I think she has the
best armbar in MMA today she's no one
has pulled it off as much as she haven't
yes she hasn't really gone against
top-level jujitsu girls but based on me
training with her I think that she can
she can tap out it's gonna be harder of
course but why do you think she's the
only one and there's all these black
belts and jiu-jitsu and MMA and they're
not they don't look anything like Ronda
Rousey why is that she's a special girl
she's very competitive she's she's a
very talented a side of this
she have a heavy training in judo which
defines her character you know defines
her desire to train hard to compete so
being a whole impact level judo player
it's being a wrestler in that level
let's bring you to a different level you
know it's not being just an athlete
she's a super athlete she's very defined
and very very much specialized and one
thing that game her game is always like
going towards the same pattern and and
the opponent's she's facing he is not
exactly prepared for that I feel like
nobody has these skills on the ground to
to fight her and nobody has the the
heavy hands and the situation to beat
her and standing up so everything is
kind of even up but go and goes to the
ground once the the opponent gets the
first throw and falls like without CNN
get lost and then she her movements are
very very effective and and will
capitalize on that but you know maybe
five fights ten fights more beautiful
wins but eventually she gonna have a
person who has the same elements and
then she gonna start to have competition
you know because so far feels like even
too easy you know it's like not even a
competition
she's like a Mike Tyson she's like when
Mike Tyson was you see how do you
eventually cyborg Rhonda's gonna happen
Dana's gonna make sure that happens
eventually how do you see that going oh
that's a interesting because you know
she will have the the preparation the
mindset the heavy hands and also the
discs you should become like a
competitor for Honda I think you know is
unpredictable like you know any fight
you know if you gotta put your money
down who would you there's no reason for
me to put my mind another person then
Honda I mean yeah I was in a good I mean
I was getting better too she's thrown
combinations with the judo throws and
her throws are just out of control
best judo in MMA yeah she's doing a man
throwing people yeah and you sure when
she fought mysha mysha is a legit
wrestler misha can wrestle and she's
making some big mistakes though she was
very high up on her above her weight was
above the hips I mean I think there was
a lot of pressure involved in that fight
she would run a mistake youth you would
think that when you in MMA generally
when someone starts doing something
that's effective that wasn't a done
before like the front snap kick that
Travis Browne is doing now Cerrone is
doing it all the time
nobody was stalling that we need to see
it first work in the UFC to go
oh man the front snap kick or the rear
leg snap kick to the chest and that's
working now so that's huge now five
years ago you know one throw they
thought it was a waste of time it
doesn't work that only works in the
movies but and there's all these kicks
head kicks and and now that we've seen
Ronda show the effectiveness of focusing
and drilling that armbar over and over
again she talks about you I do you think
people aren't paying attention to it and
aren't going look what works look what
happens with the armbar when you do it a
hundred thousand times let's do that
let's do you think they're not doing it
because she's a girl
no one's paying attention really you
think is easy I mean hair performance is
it reflects reflects a life even her
parents are involved in judo yeah so is
a lifetime of achievements is that a
subconscious reflex it's not something
which you educate people is like you
don't think you could learn it if you
practice hard enough you have to be like
at least a classification phase to go to
the top top ten in judo is not just
learn is dedicate yourself your sweat
and tears and blood intensity to get
there you know it's like being as you
Jitsu champion is one thing doing what
cron does today is another thing he is
not only fighting hard but he goes and
train hard and run hard and lift weights
whatever he does he does with the
compromise to excel and that's a mindset
it's not exactly you teach is something
I believe Honda is a special girl
because she put herself in that kind of
level of stress and she handle and she I
mean the train is hard
the focus is hard she's serious and the
whole formula is there to support her
her victories you not it's not a flake
or it's not a Slugger it's not oh you
you learn come here let me show you how
to defend the unlock and now you go you
ready to fight it's not like that you
know it's so anyone in the in the mixed
martial arts coming from a background
because they see mixed martial arts AG
as a good exposure as a good situation
to make money to make so they come in
with average background to try you know
their best they sometimes having from
the the hasni family and then learning
some box some jujitsu some defense and
go they coming from the judo and go
they got me from the the jujitsu and go
and learn a little bit here and there
but very few are like like Randy Couture
which is already established champion
like like Coleman you know guys who have
defined their lives in one thing and
then they breed to another but they have
already the sense of you know they
believe in themselves they can
capitalize on the mistakes they forward
forever so those things you know you
don't bind on the only the work ethic or
the supermarket you know those things is
lifetime experience and is how chew yeah
the intensity that Ronda Rousey brings
to training just to life itself it's
very difficult to replicate and that it
has it resonates throughout everything
she does yes she's crazy
yeah now when in the best one with Kron
went against Shin yay okey I'm assuming
that you studied a lot of Shinya Aoki
tapes
what do you I personally think
one of the best at jujitsu in MMA as far
as he's gotten so many submissions you
get you with leg locks
he has a great rear naked choke his
guards really good yeah um were you
impress by watching tape of Virginia
Shinya is not only I impressed by tapes
the first boudoir challenge I did he win
with honors you know he winded the
Buddha challenge and submitting
everybody you know he won your yeah the
Buddha has different weight divisions in
his way division he makes you fights and
submit both and who were the guys do you
remember what two guys well I didn't
even really know who he was in 2005 to
tell the truth then you already know
yeah so anyway I felt how tired
how tight how tied to how precision his
submission he got a flying army lock in
the first guy and the foot lock in the
second guy so I felt like his very verse
versatile you know he has a highlight
reel in Judah where he would be flying
arm bars in judo just yes one after
another and that's what something I
absorb in then I'd like we in our
training we've grown I said and we kind
of decide true because he was very
comfortable when you engage on the grid
so from your grip he can go for a flying
triangle flying on lots and such so cron
was pressing him without in engage using
the food and trying to make him feel
like he has to engage not chrome
grabbing so that's kind of give the
first the first way for him to feel like
lost he was expecting chrome to attempt
but chrome was pressing without grabbing
if you see the fight again you see so
and at one point they engage chrome
poach the guard and he was kind of
trying to stay and chrome go to the head
once he can escape and then chrome
finish with the headlock as when they
roll but the guy is very tough we are
not worried about the Jiu Jitsu back in
for like the attempts him to submit
Chronos or hard to catch because chrome
is very skilled to defend well is he
good at defending like locks crown yes
yes
but still the opportunity was raised
based on his his desire to act so we
forced him to act he gave what we want
and kronk catch precisely and sharpen
and was over every every morning well
every time I work out and go to the gym
I warm up on the Stairmaster and I just
go ADCC marcelo garcia or whoever and I
just I just want to warm up and watch
people do jiu-jitsu at a high level and
that just gets my blood boiling I just
want to go lift weights right so I'm
watching Marcelo and Crone and Matt
recently and I'm water last one yeah and
I haven't watched it in a while but man
I'm so used to Marcelo just going
through everybody
Marcelo just washes he is unbelievable
what he does people go to his gym he's
like hey you can come to my gym I'll
roll with you but we're gonna videotape
it and we're gonna put it on the
Internet yeah deal and then I everyone
that goes there's like Oh Matt here's
like they're walking into the
slaughterhouse right he puts on
everyone's gonna see the role so that's
and he just crushes everybody big dudes
and then for him when when he went
against groan he passed groans guard for
a couple seconds but then after that
initial he it was a double leg dragon he
jumped and then bones ability to recover
full guard is unlike anybody I've ever
seen you rarely see full guard in Abu
Dhabi people stay away from full guard
but chrome will force unis force marcelo
garcia and crone into full garden
marcelo was having a hard time and then
he broke he finally broke open his full
guard then he tried to pass again and
then he's back in full guard again and
then um you know chrome put him in a
guillotine and the word is and Marcel I
think admits this yeah he went out like
he went out to him he said what stuff
you know I almost pass out and then but
chrome he because was going in the end
of the mat did the first like the round
he was trying to save himself for for
the next round so he he put pressure and
then he kind of said that I kind of just
try to hold instead keep him
putting all my power so and then I mean
nothing happened and the guy kind of
survived and he kind of won they want to
take down so he could have cat he could
have put him to sleep there if it's
possible I mean you know but that's
always the thing with the guillotine
knowing whether or not to exert all your
energy yes yes but Kron specialized in
the guillotine I mean he coming in the
next for the next for the last Abu Dhabi
prepared to to face Marcelo again and he
is Collini his progress is being very
very you know progressive and and he was
ready but firstly Marcel didn't didn't
come and he made great fights and he
displayed like especially the guillotine
against Antonio what a view
what's great in the final the guy just
when he jumps and I feel like you guys
about the chick I don't believe it I'm
like someone explain it to people who
didn't hear our other podcast
well well Crown winner in 2013 Abu Dhabi
Kron showed up and did with with what
only I think maybe jean-jacques did it
Marcelo did it and I think maybe haja
Gracie did it I'm not sure that he went
in and submitted all four of his
opponents and in the he submitted Garry
tonin in an amazing match would guess my
best fights I saw incredible yeah it was
incredible I was losing my mind watching
that one and and he submitted JT Torres
who's a beast jttours so good and he got
him from the guard he got he just had
the over hook and he just flipped his
leg over his face and just held on to
the over so it's kind of like one of
those overlooked arm bars and and then
he beat who did he beat first I don't
know but the first one was like I'm not
sure his name but he put a guy to sleep
and then get this Gary guy in the first
day yeah and then James's second day in
GT and dermatology and then Auto be on
the finals well the match we're talking
about and me and Joe talked about this
and they made a Stewart Cooper made a
film on it but otvio Souza his strategy
was to not be on his back stay on top
and just kind of maybe get a takedown
late you know cuz that's a you know that
rule format or that points format in
abu-dhabi that back happens a lot people
will just wrestle in Russell and Russell
and he wasn't engaging and Crone is like
like just like Hickson saying he's like
Marcello he's like he goes after it he's
gonna go 100% all he wants is the
submission that's korone he's a special
grappler special fighter all he wants is
the submission and otvio wasn't really
engaging and as a father no no no not as
a fan as a coach I saw his coach as the
fight progress the guys st. you what
I've in Portuguese okay man that's it
that's all you want okay keep going it's
perfect perfect perfect and I see a guy
just running from the fight and making
strategy which kind of upset me
completely I mean it's nothing perfect
on that in my sense and but in this
strategic aspect of his his doing so I
have to counter in somehow and then I
start to make try to suggest the referee
he was escaping he was tried to avoid
the fight because he's not positive
points in the first 10 minutes but his
negative point so I was hoping for a
negative point to which dot for this is
stalling so and then I start to say hey
free the guy start removing like you
know he don't wanna engage he's just
moving back like a chicken and as the
things start to boiling I start to say
hey man this guy like a chicken and the
whole stage was this quiet watching the
fight is just this noise kind of
overwhelming everything throw a chicken
inside that and for a jiu-jitsu
competitor first of all I mean I know
you're right here but I just have to be
honest everybody says you're the
greatest ever
you're the greatest jiu-jitsu competitor
of all time so you're here the greatest
jiu-jitsu representative of all time
your son is competing this guy has to
respect you and admire you and you're
going block the whole crowd is listen to
this I mean that's a lot of pressure on
that guy not having to his head because
I was suggesting the referee he needs to
be punished
and eventually like with 90 minutes or
so he get - points and that's what's
exactly what generates him to say okay
now I'm honey bee honey running behind
so I have to make it happen and as we're
talking afterwards we've grown
come on said dad when I do start you
talking like a chicken I felt like he
won't explode I'm I don't want to make a
mistake wasting the opportunity but I
know he will coming so I was just ready
for it
so we're kind of working together you
know like the father and son work was
perfect he's shot right in and then he's
already waited football was over yeah
ice cream that's one thing that's the
one thing John Jacques would tell me
because tranfer jean-jacques trained me
for metamoris and we would talk about
Krohn and and jean-jacques said I asked
Sean John what is groans best technique
he goes man that guillotine he wraps his
arms around your head he's got an
incredible squeeze yes that the
guillotine used to be a strong man move
like I used to think like even the arm
and guillotine like that's a strong man
I never got into guillotines but over
the last 10-15 years they've gotten so
oh man I said I tell you I'm always been
trying to specialize myself and all the
submissions and I have my guillotine
which you know gives me some victories
but you know and then one day one time I
was talking with groan and it's not even
one day on the mat was in the locker
room and then I said yeah but get a team
crown you have the guy can escape said
no that doesn't scare but said now
escape I said no he said no if I get it
said oh come on and grab me man I tap
you and then I have to rethink my whole
strategy said yeah this guy have just
you know you already have something to
tell him it's levels of squeeze right no
it's a level of grip it's a level of
grab the way you hold is all technical
and this the regular escape doesn't work
anymore so of course we have escape for
Crohn's
I'm a guillotine but it's a different
than I was visualizing so I have to
relearn how to escape from average
guillotines and close guillotine so it
has to be special the defense those
levels the technical
levels are lost on a lot of people that
are just watching it the differences
little variation that is the essence of
jiu-jitsu yes I believe the Beast the
biggest aspect of jiu-jitsu is invisible
my I pray I mean I my my my
I preach the invisible jiu-jitsu because
it is invisible because you see it but
you don't see it you see the same God
position you see the same mount but you
have to feel it you know I I base my
jiu-jitsu and how you feel not what you
see and that's is totally different when
I go in and seminars and stuff the guy
feel different they say wow man I've
been doing this all my life and I never
felt this way it's oh so good okay
there's so much leverage so so based on
the weight distribution based on the on
the on the sense of leverage and all
this can change the same position you've
seen a picture cannot be worth it or can
be very much effective depending how the
grip the angle the elbows the weight so
is amazing how the invisible jiu-jitsu
is what really supports the you know
it's not what you learn superficially
what do you think about Marcelo Garcia's
variation of the guillotine you know and
some people called a high elbow
guillotine and a lot of people call to
Marcel a team where it's it's he doesn't
believe like this yeah what have you is
that part of something that you've
taught her is that new to you know is
not new is an option which developed by
him like his he's the master on there is
not so you see different submissions
from the brag yeah mission so it's
adaptations you know if you focus and
you know what's coming and you have
defenses I don't believe a guillotine is
effective regardless no yeah all the
guillotines you can defend but you have
to be precise if you make one mistake if
you're thinking about defense one and
the guy come in with a little twist the
defense one is not going to work and if
you think about change for the second
you already tapping or you already
sleeping yes so you have to be precise
on on the adaptation of each so now if
chrome gets me I know exactly what I
have to go if I delayed five two seconds
then comes over yeah is over so and
that's his go
for any any technique there's so many
different ways to squeeze the neck
I would off the top of my head you know
including all the armand chokes like the
Darce and the Japanese necktie the arm
and guillotine the different grips all
these different neck cranks there's
gotta be just those the nose Iver swans
like how you called the neck breaks from
like the one the twister yes really a
choke that's a straight neck guys yeah
but there's so many ways just noogie
there's so many ways to put someone to
sleep I would say there's 15 to 20
different ways nogi to squeeze a neck
everyone's got their own different
styles did you get into cuz one of the
most popular chokes over the last 10-15
years and then the nogi grappling seen
is the Darce are you familiar what is it
bravo choke it's it's the Bravo choke it
just squeeze but it's the arm the back
no no from topside oh like yes like half
I'm in half guard like in half guard and
you come in it's like have an over hook
and you come and use that one that's
become just the one of the most basic
standard chokes and it came sort of from
a wrestling three-quarter nelson
technique that was used to flip people
over and then I think it was Dave
Terrell showed it to Joe Darcy and then
everyone mark layman started calling it
Joe Darsh because he learned from Joe
darts but he he actually I don't know
John Danaher there's a whole story but
the name stuck the Darce was that
something that you guys were doing back
in the 70s and 80s that's more of a
newer truth and people are stating that
the origins of the triangle like just
the leg triangle there's so many
different theories on where how that got
injected into Helios style and I do you
know the origins of a trial or is it
just an old technique no I mean if
you're going out the book techniques
you're gonna see all the submissions you
know like the application of triangles
in my life it starts you coming by by
understanding the cost
left and seeing like longer guys looking
like Makaha guys with long legs like
Matthew Matthew Makaha is like okay old
school I saw guys doing this and I start
to apply you know I start to you my legs
are not too long so I have to pick the
perfect positions to do but I start to
get you know familiar with and I mean
it's just you know it's hard to say
where I come from but it's I have I have
my open mind like the the Eric Paulson
situation if they knew I'll always have
open mind to accept to to embrace things
are functional you know and discard
everything which I don't like it you
know it's not about theory it's not
about it's about effective and it's
about the results is about few comforts
about there so anything I see no matter
if it's from Bruce Lee or from any race
or a catch catch gun or if I see and I
like and I gonna be going experiment
immediately because I just add to my
arsenal you know it's that's the concept
which leads you to development to to
progression and to success it's one of
the beautiful things about jiu-jitsu is
that it's constantly growing if always
new techniques the idea that you know
the Darce choke wasn't around when you
were competing and now it's a staple a
mainstay it's fascinating
I have to bring this up because if I
didn't bring this up everybody online
would go crazy there's a videotape of
when yogi and Joe showed up at your dojo
yes and you you you know you saw it
no no I've never seen no that's maybe
next barbecue and my house that's what
you want to let's plan it the way the
world wants this yeah the world will you
will you release it to the world
probably eventually oh no you gotta
release it that's one of the number one
things that people are when I hit couple
middle people on my site I may do that
will do or free on this uh make that
happen I will make that happen
tell us that story how did that story
come about oh just when I finished the
valley to the 95 was a legit eight-man
tournament and I won
he started like the WWF in like as a UFO
in Japan was very strong with progress
pro wrestling like big magazines like a
huge Japanese love pro wrestling so and
then based on that kind exposure of this
new event the champion of the wrestling
association one of the champions of the
UFO called Takeda I start to talk oh I
like to fight here they ask him and they
start to talking like all the pro
wrestlers talk I gonna kick his ass this
that started talking a lot of gossip and
at this point I'm back to LA maybe after
2 or 3 months of this kind of talking
around my name forever some guys some
some wanted friends I have in Japan they
come and said mister grace they talking
a lot about you and you should have
official answer for that you know you
cannot just let because people start
thinking you afraid people so you have
to have official answer so I said okay
so I make a letters stating I will never
will fight on their ring because they
not legit they fix fights so that's
against my if they if you wanna come and
fight in my event like they not mine but
the event I fight them Japan open here
we welcome to come and we want to face
which other for sure if in other case we
can fight even on the street but I'm not
there to fight on his event because
that's will deployed eyes my real fight
status a real fighter stairs so with
this being said cup what might maybe few
weeks later
Takada went out of the the the gossip
and then I'll just show up in a magazine
static he started saying he will come
into LA to beat me up he will do this
because because he said are you gonna
fight for free so I wanna dare to fight
to kick so and then Kai coming hey
mister I just say he's come and said
this said man I cannot lost my sleep
based on his own on just speculations
you know he said when I come no he
didn't said okay so I gonna keep my life
and if we show up ok he show up so past
may be a couple of weeks or so
more'n one day I was in home in the
morning
my assistant at the school Coleman said
Hickson some guys here some Japanese
guys are here waiting for you want to
talk to you and immediately I figured
out support could be that situation so I
put my camera in my hand hawks on once
you come in with me he was about 11
years old I was going back driving my
car taping my hands because I know we're
gonna be a so I was putting tape in my
hands as I driving in the freeway when I
arrived I saw a van full up with
photographers outside you know like the
eye passing through my parking lot and I
so I came foo of Japanese with cameras
full of reporters inside so I come it
went through when I get in the school I
saw a huge like a tall Japanese guy very
well-dressed and a lady and I
immediately hey how are you Oh mr.
Gracey I'm the president of the UFO
Association I come here to officially
invite you to participate of a fight in
Japan and I said man you crazy I told
you I don't want to fight in Japan and
under your Association and then once I
when I kind of deflect the direction he
said yeah but you also said you fight
for free for your owner and she said yes
I am here to fight I expect fighting you
but you come into negotiable fighters
outside
can you come he come he said yes he can
come in so I tell my student to say hey
you stand the door let the lady with the
fighter come in but don't let the
reporters come in block everybody
outside I didn't know what's going to
happen I don't want to press so as I
drew come in we fought like an ugly face
and attitude and stuff I immediately
asked my structure sadly mom grabbed the
waiver and tell him to sign that's like
if I get hurt whatever those waivers so
he looked the waiver we fugly face and
then he spoke with with his guy in
Japanese and then the Japanese guy said
Mr Gracie
you mean if he don't sign you don't
fight immediately I felt like if I say
yeah he has to sign they may leave and
they're gonna come in with all the
excuse ah he chickened out
I immediately said no forget the paper
if you come in to fight let's fight
forget the bureaucracy let's let's make
something here more simple so and then
he come into the match should a ring I
you know and we start to fighting
immediately I felt his intention to hit
me immediately i clinch put him on the
ground and start supine she turned back
but different than a normal event where
just put him to sleep or whatever in
that particular case I have to display
showcase his punishment so I was not
happy just to put him to sleep
so I start to hit him with the elbow
respect him to turn eventually he turned
and I punch him in the face and Q broke
his nose and make it all bleed all cut a
cut up and at that point when he felt
like I felt like he was just smash
enough he turned again backwards and I
put him to sleep and then I let him
sleeping on his own blood and then I
said to the press said okay now let them
in so when the press come in saw him
passing out waking up with the guy
trying to hide his face from the
pictures and the guys OD is he waking up
all blood you know a big big mess of
blood in the floor and stuff and the
crowd my students kind of lift me up I
kind of might my t-shirt is all bloody
and I kind of hang on the on the wall
like a trophy and stuff and we all
yelling so the guy stood up and and left
and then like three or four days later
Andrew come back to me and at my school
I was teaching he caught me with a
package and said oh I like to talk he
was still like all bruised and stuff so
they I like to apologize and I like to
give you this as a gift and he gave me a
samurai helmet and and then he left
Japan and when he get there
he say to the crowd he was jumped you
know I was jumped the guys jumped me
Herrera because the press didn't saw and
then I get my assistant my Japanese guy
who was working with me and they valley
to the 95 and I said listen you D you
take this tape you go to Japan make a
press conference display don't make one
copy nothing make sure no no please so
go there make shoulder depress and come
back and bring this back okay so he went
make the press conference and then my
reputation when they saw was like a free
fair fight and what happened my
reputation went to this to the roof and
you know it's just a big step for me and
like in the publicity because I
capitalized and all the wrestling
publicity which is national in Japan so
in then then my next fight eventually
was with Takada he accept the fight and
make official fight and then we create
the pride I help in the formulation of
the the rules a lot of folks don't know
that you were a big part of the original
pride yeah they asked me if I want to
fight Takada and for that they want to
create a new event
I said yes I fight him and then we
discussed numbers and and an order
should make a good rule I helped in the
rules because you know cannot be so I
introduced the gloves and the MMA and
they mix martial arts and the first but
I said yeah we have to put gloves
because without glue can be too bloody
we have to cut head butts and stuff so I
make like a draw of the the backbone of
what could be and then from that they
start the pride I fought the pride won
the pride for and then the pride becomes
like huge in Japan and then because they
have a little involvement with the
Yakuza the sponsors they have Fuji TV
like pull it off and they carrying
problems to the payroll which is here
they have maybe 50 top fat athletes
making a lot of money so they could not
handle in the end you have see come and
take over and get all the footage and
the fighters and now bring for the next
level they took a huge bath because UFC
played 65 million dollars for Pride and
all all the contracts
were fake yeah they're all void there
they're invalid rather none of them were
legal so I didn't know that so USC had
the worst of it they weighed the worst
of it they tried to sue Japan or they
tried to sue the organization why it's
kind of funny this is how crafty they
were while the UFC purchased pride the
people that were running Pride were
starting another organization while they
were working for the UFC so they were
working for the USC running the pride
offices for the UFC in Japan but then
they were running their own interest is
we don't know disregard of everything
now there's a japanese-style there's a
classic there's a classic match or not a
match fight that got it's on video it
might be on YouTube with you and Hugo
Dority on the beach where you guys are
fighting what is that on you - oh yeah
yeah parts of it it's hard to see the
whole thing I know they fight on the
beach do you know who is holding that
the camera at that day was high end with
12 years old in hawksin was 7
jean-jacques was there
there's Jacques running so what was the
reasoning behind that fight how did that
go down ok let's make this the last day
alright guys okay so if not - gonna talk
forever here about things from the past
okay I'd love to talk about present but
anyway was a great time because at this
point
mahua was just finishing fight Fernando
Fernando pin dukkha and I an event after
my second fight of Zulu in Mireille this
jiu-jitsu community has a little
friction with the loot delivery
community so they set up a fight between
was Marcel bearing against Fabio Melina
hey man against Oh Jeanette Adele and
then pinned oka against maka hua and
they draw and after that draw ma hua
creates a good status of being a great
fighter as it is it's a good you know
tough guy and the gossip starts to
become like
and then people may ask him what about
Higson so and then in the kind of small
world is a position where mark who is as
willing to fight me and I also of course
we need to fight him but I don't want to
wait or give him the reputation where I
challenge him is not the case he was
just first I was already famous
established he was already a coming up
like just make a good fight so to make
things more simple my my father myself
Marcelo and Sara my best friend we went
to his school in a day and a night time
he had maybe 50 guys training all
without G they all tough they all have a
lot of pumping iron so they all big guys
you know so I went to his place said who
as I like to talk to you so he coming to
me I said hey man I heard you you spot
you you to showing desire to fight me so
I like to fight you anytime you want
regardless let's do it if you want to do
now you can do tomorrow whatever and you
look at me I said yeah but it's not like
that
if you challenge me I may accept but I
have I need four months to train I said
man you crazy you think like I use all
the names but I it's like you think the
Lakers will challenge a college
basketball team from from from Cucamonga
what are you talking about you can't hit
your child I'm not I come here too
because I heard you planing to fight and
if you fight here you wanna fight or not
so when this conversation start to
become a little my dad coming as a
mediator said hey guys I don't want to
discuss let's make a list if somebody
wants to fight hitch let's make a list
and then eventually you guys can can
fight and then we'll go from the back
you can put my name on that list and I
first time I saw you in my life and I
look at him and said yeah man you tell
me this is not a because has a game a
gambling in Brazil like a popular game
not official but an unofficial game
called jogo do bicho means game of the
animals
you put a name I'm a number like 24 is
the is the deer so a guy put a $1 and if
he wins again maybe $50 something very
popular every in every corner has this
kind of underground game and I said to
him this is not a game of animals man
this is just a serious business you
don't have to put your name in the list
if you want to fight let's fight right
now and the guy can I get me little
confused so enough in happen and then we
decide to leave so we left after that
the whole gasp every corner I heard who
go astray need to fight you would start
to first talking about whoo whoo whoo
whoo and I felt like this has to have an
end you know another guy could not
challenge officially because he's a
nobody but it's a guy if I just
disregard it's something who's gonna be
against me true because I know he has
the potential he's a fighter he just not
had the name but he's a legitimate tough
guy so based on that I could not just
ignore and I could not challenge him
officially so I have to do something in
between which fight him on the street so
we decide to find a final okay let's
make a profile where he goes what bitch
he go where he walks about so we decide
he wasn't at this Beach with a very
popular Beach and in real every Sun
every Saturday Sunday he is there with
the okay so next Sunday we're gonna be
there Saturday so I was at this point
separate from my my relationship I was
living like a single in Rio and that's
very hard to do because a lot of options
so I was not concerned about the fight
at all I was no sleep on the Monday
Tuesday like just going party a lot wake
up on Wednesday kind of afternoon walk
on the street close to my neighborhood
and then I saw a friend of mine who's
always in the gossip said hey and as I
leaving home I said I think I gonna
postpone who goes fight for the
following week I don't think it's gonna
be a good idea because man I'm just
too much body when I get on the street
man first time I see first guy I saw it
was this my friend bauru who's just
coming said man you should see
everybody's prepared everybody talking
about the fight will be great they are
all waiting they all will be there and I
say oh my god no postponement anymore I
have to go regardless so so as I
approach the weekend I try to just
recover sleep eat well but still like
not enough anyway Saturday morning we
all gathering in the in the Gracie Baja
Academy which is close to the
neighborhood and and we're getting like
the students because we have to have a
team to to be there you know what you
hold and whatever so it's about 50 to 60
guys there and we all kind of
strategizing okay you guys make this and
that and and then my son was seven years
old all pumping up and then and one
point everybody quiet he's just jumping
the mute and said yeah and if his son
will be there I gonna kick his ass so
he's already with the DNA of the viral
so was funny and then eventually about
10 o'clock or so he arrived on the beach
the guide the messenger come is they are
there so so you went to the beach and as
we approached the beach I have the
camera nobody wants to hold the cam no
no no not me so I give the camera to
Haiyan which 12 years old at the time
and he could not get through its just
yelling everybody he could not get
through to - but you film the fight the
film was not even important so we engage
was at the moment the first engage after
a slap him we engage very quickly and
and then we start to house on the sand
he fall on top of me I was kind of
having a hard time from from the
beginning and then I able to sweep
mounted and he escaped from the mount
one more time because the scent give me
no base so I kind of messed my knee on
the sand so he come up I have to sweep
him again mounted again at that time
much more
concern of keeping the position so I
grabbed his hand like like from the back
and I started to punching him like
Funaki yeah yeah exactly like like I
started punching him punching elbow
punch punch punch punch and then in one
point I was dead dead tired I asked him
you want to give up he said you have to
kill me I said okay punching punching
punch and then immediately afterwards he
said okay stop stop stop so I
immediately stopped we went to the water
dive on the waters come back as we come
back he said yeah I'm not happy I said
okay let's do it again said no no not
today
and I said okay man that's okay and then
hands we start to fighting my cell
Mandy's at the beach they started
getting it then the doesn't have the end
it's just kind of mess it up a little
bit him so confront with the guy but was
not an end fight anyway I put stitches
on my hand
and back like I'll swallow my hands off
swallows so I went back home training
resting giving my life
one week later you know I was in a part
a friend of Mines apartment
you know resting tired from some little
fun I was laid down you know in my
underwears my hair I have long hair at
the time but all messy a guy my student
of mine just stopping the bender on the
on the street on the bike and said hex
on Hickson they invited in this school
is invading it's a big invasion I said I
kind of wake up and run down and when he
saw me running under where's you go like
that I said hey man I jump in the back
let's go so I went to the to my school
in your in my underwear with the hell
crazy and I and as I approached the
school because they coming from a
different neighborhood walking and and
one of the guys like you're Jenna today
was a black guy who lives in a ghetto as
they approach they come he walk if maybe
five like three or four miles you know
something like that a different
neighborhood they coming like from the
street
so as they come in like it's not only
fighters that's bad guys guys with like
all the eyes I mean only the uncover
eyes with with guns with knives with
bottle break so it's a lot of Cove
oceans a lot of image bad energy not
coming from a real fight situation but
it's more like a street dangerous so as
I approach and I coming through the
crowd which is already controlling maybe
two-thirds off the street which passing
cars just could not pass in cars anymore
just like just the car passing are very
fine lines a big crowd in front of the
school so I went through with the bike
when I coming up to the school he's
already coming down with my father the
news on which his struct or other guys
they coming down and we we kind of crush
each other in the in the middle of the
stairs I said okay man let's go down
let's talk so we can went down to the
parking lot and like crowded maybe 20
guys from my school one guy has a weapon
but the other guys maybe five or six ten
guns and knives I mean it's a bad bad
weather you know
so before I start the fight I said oh I
like to talk to you come over let's talk
let's walk to the backyard here so my
father myself the news on hollering and
the genja today we kind of move away
from the crowd which were like a
backyard and I said man I I want to talk
to you something very important listen I
fought to you last week as a man and I
come here I respect you as a fighter to
challenge me to rematch so all this is
cool regardless who win who lost but if
somebody touched the fight before the
fight is over because you bring here a
lot of people without know martial arts
code so if somebody touches the fight
before it's over I guarantee you man you
wake up on the ditch and said no now
it's a man man-to-man despised honor
thinks ok let's go back let's talk
finish book so we went back to the crowd
they make a arena in like
people make a circle and was on the
concrete and I felt when we start I felt
like his mentor whatever she was
supposed to say to him hey man
the first fight last week you engaged
too quickly you give the grappling hook
you should punch him in the face so I
felt a completely different animal
because he was already trying to buy his
approach his position he's the way he
moves I felt like he wants to punch me
different then was before and I kind of
make myself like available I kind of
played on me you know like play kind of
touch and he come and punch me right
there I deflected very quick grab him in
around the waist like hi
make a little hip movement and put him
or rosante and throw him on the concrete
so he fell flat on the concrete I tried
to mount hitch scape I move like to the
other side and mount again and I'm that
by mountain on him like with 15 maybe 20
seconds I just wanted on him I punch he
covered up and I could not punch anymore
so I get his everything and bang his
head against the concrete a few times
you know boom he kind of Bank the head
on the floor and then he softer up a
little bit I give him a couple of points
he kind of quit immediately stop stop
stop for me it was not exactly the well
done job because it was just too quick
and he quick he quit very quickly so I
want to do the something else but the
crowd was already trying to it's too
much I said if I insist here after his
arts ask for mercy can jeopardize the
whole thing so even though I was not
happy I stood up and he stood up in this
area I mean I'm happy I'm satisfied now
you would really the man shake hands say
yeah man you have a very valuable guide
shoe very strong keep training you can
be good so we can i end up our it our
our different yes so once we out of that
high let's touch of high let's start to
fight the urogenital deal in the same
because they already having a little so
they start to fighting at that point the
police come in a guy with a gun machine
just because nobody would listen the
was nothing so he kind of make a
shooting the the roof the bullets come
up and bring some some Rica shit down
and somebody got hit and then he come
his very small guy before cigarettes and
I what I see who is the tough guy now
now so it's a very small guy who forgot
machine so he go everybody like quiet so
and then I talk with the new said hey
man the fighters just start here with
fighter has to go next week we're gonna
set up something that's not and yet
today I let so we we set up for a
different day when then it's over formue
and we kind of end up with a respectful
honorable way and that's pretty much it
that's a great story no more old stories
that's it because all night we can hit
whatever here man that's wrong with that
guys you know this is the biggest
response ever on Twitter for a guest
like I don't know about your Twitter but
my Twitter people are going nuts that
you're doing the podcast and they've
been going nuts
ever since the yo gngo tape there's
screaming please release the tape please
release the tape will you release it
yeah let's do that okay yeah let's keep
the the couple of million people in this
site okay we'll do our best to get as
many people on the site so what are you
were you sending people what's the site
what's the address
jayjay GF dot-com jiu-jitsu global
Federation calm so just the initial JJ
gif calm it's all set up right now
beautiful so I wanted to ask you
something about what's going on today in
in MMA there's like like Nick Diaz and
there's been a bunch of guys that have
been suspended and fine for having
cannabis in their system and there's big
controversy because in a lot of states
now it's 23 states in the United States
where it's legal now so how do you feel
about a banning cannabis as a
performance enhancer do you think I mean
what do you think about man I think you
know we are I mean since the the
beginning of the times drugs are always
involved with for us not dress drugs for
body drugs or alright
but I totally talking about painkillers
we talking about coffee we're talking
about
we're talking about I mean teas and
herbs and so we all wish to mate to use
medicines and drugs to in haze to
diminish to a calm to cook so this is is
is there you know I think that kind of
judgment goes from person to person from
you know some people can have a little
bit of some drug and get a reaction
which can make him crazy or can make him
addicted or can make him so that the
chemical in the brain can respond
differently yes
for some people cannabis is a medicine
as they play for others can be a
stimulant or can be a below I mean low
your self esteem becomes bipolar if you
smoke you can be I mean I mean you don't
know yeah it makes you more of what you
are kind of right it's hard to say what
is so at that point I feel like we have
to obey the law you know and if if some
kind of drugs are forbidden by law for
you to become a pro act athlete you have
to obey that if you not that career what
you do in your life you know it has to
be respected has to be you know whatever
but what's the rules for MMA I mean I
try to input in the jiu-jitsu the
anti-doping
you know because you see guys in the
same way division but one guy has ten
times more endurance ten times more
power ten times alright so other guys
that you know has addictive like he has
a extra I extra enhancement so we have
to balance this in arm in order to make
a fair sport how much the Kanab is
affect the athlete I'm not sure you know
and but I know orders like steroids or
hormones those are proving so whatever
is being proved against use the cannabis
for fighting for sports activities if
it's proved this kind of support of I
mean the drug use can be in hazing son
maybe we cut I don't know it's up to
them the real problem answers it's it's
there they're testing people for
something
stays in your body for a long time after
its psychoactive so if you took cannabis
like a week before your fight you're not
gonna be high when you're fighting but
it's still gonna be in your system so
you're still gonna be penalized for
something that's what's what's the
reason
what's the reason why they took it yeah
because you can have caffeine in your
blood you can have like another kind of
why the cannabis has to be because I
don't think his enhancement of
performance I think is only control your
emotional give you kind of some kind of
feeling of happiness sometimes if give
you like a little laziness you know I
don't think that's will help you as an
athlete I think if you get if you get
high before event you're gonna lose your
sharpeners you want it so I don't think
that's we support so I don't see why
they have to bother in legalizing or
before beating I don't know maybe it's
just because of the law just because
it's illegal and the reason why it's
illegal has nothing to do with whether
or not it's safe or dangerous there's
nothing it's all political with but they
did lower it right you know it used to
be good a few of you if you were in
Colorado let's say where it's totally
legal it's it's not illegal there
anybody can smoke in Colorado you could
buy it you can buy it in vending
machines you have to stop a month before
your fight because it's it's still gonna
show up in the test and you could lose
the fight the fights are no contest you
get fined so now they're kind of
changing and adapting now I guess
according to the numbers I think you can
go you have to stop two weeks before a
fight or something like that so it may
be eventually
depending of the car they have to change
the fight for Colorado yeah or the
training camp being in Colorado so
everything there is legal but there
there are there definitely how do you
say relaxing the rules or you wouldn't
say that what are they what's the word
they made it from it used to be fifty
nanograms per milliliter to 150 so it
changed quite a bit 300% increase so you
have 300 more marijuana in your system
well there's that the step in the right
direction I think now I'm as far as
performing
enhancing surfing is a serious sport
that requires serious technique lots of
hours and generally you you you hear
that surfers will be under the influence
of cannabis while they're surfing it
wouldn't it if it if it makes your
reflexes some people believe that it
makes its a dulls your reflexes
how can surfers be under the influence
of cannabis and ride a 25-foot wave know
the the the way the ocean is he's an
animal you know is alive is in movement
it can be dangerous
has this kind of you have to have the
perfect lecture lamian you have to have
two paths mapping the way out the way in
so it's a lot of strategy it's a lot of
technique and it's also is a lot of
harmonii between you as a surfer in the
ocean so you have to find yourself
comfortable you have to find yourself a
spirit to the connect to the force and
sometimes some of guys who my friends
who kind of normally smoke some they
feel peaceful and they get in the
Armani's no it's not about stayin use
physical only if you get caught in the
bad situation against the bad report you
have to swim like a dog you're a good
surfer you started the whole of my life
what's the biggest wave you've ever surf
third bunk no no about 12 feet okay so
all I do is dangerous long board short
board short board okay I'm a short board
a yes and Crone surface to grow surface
but he's just he is more passionate
about jiu-jitsu than then certain - do
you surf still oh depends as well I have
to check surf line today oh really so
you might surf every day yeah that much
huh oh yeah what is it about surfing is
about
for me is about the water the ocean
because I believe in energy I believe in
and the ocean being the most the most
the hugest electromagnetic pole on earth
all the electricity coming from so as I
go in the ocean if I'm stressed I get
energy if I'm you know lazy I get energy
if I'm too tense
I got relaxed so is I equal Iser for me
because I feel like the contact with the
ocean keep me in balance keep me so for
me it's not about the perfect wave it's
about going to the ocean make my routine
make my exercise breathing you know I'm
a tropical rat I'm born and raised in
Rio so I cannot stay away from the water
this is just the you know somehow the
energy flow and how spiritually that's
kinda have empower me understand and
that you would say that physically
surfing does translate did you get to as
far as the balance right cuz you need
incredible balance not really I think it
is of course you you stimulates your
your your neuromuscular activity in
surfing and skate and and and rigid but
I think the most important thing in
surfing is as you become under pressure
you have which we strategize you have to
be in control of your emotions you have
to be focused in and everything do right
and if things go wrong you have to be
fine your comfortable zone inhale and
that's the mindset is similar because
the ocean is not your enemy but he's
there to do his think and he's very
powerful so you have to find her your
Mentos your mindset you find comfortable
in all this turmoil you know it's all
you know it's if you get caught in a
wrong position and if you get panic he's
gone so you have to be calm same thing
then fight you have to have like the
focus the strategy and even when things
with the problem rises you have to be in
control what do you do with your time
these days like what's a typical day for
Hicks and Gracie
right now I beg to teach in Chrome's
place because I wanted to to have him
more distress with the how the Academy
goes so I pick two times a week to teach
they're giving self-defense classes at
this point before that I was doing
seminars once a month at the most once
twice every couple of months to make my
living and also because I feel like the
best things in life money cannot buy and
I feel like the quality of my my my
meals the way I eat the way my
relationship my sleep those are very
very valuable assets you know plus the
time I have to do things I love to do
that's kind of when this is fuel like
when I feel like I'm everything so I
feel like I'm happy enough to be my best
at service because I always try to be at
service helping somebody with jiu-jitsu
with knowledge with nutrition with
breathing you know it's not about the
prices about the service you know and
then I put my head in the yeah I have a
nice day I make a good speech with Joe
Hogan I'd have a garage talk with Ed
Bravo was great day so somehow in a
purpose for the Federation so I always
try to be positive but I have no
schedule fixed like I have to wake up
vote you know because at this point I
create a lifestyle which make me feel
good to engage in different elements
like this Federation now and having
classes on crowns and be here to be full
of energy you know because sometimes you
don't notice but based on your your your
commitments your obligation you becoming
more like a Robert and you you lose the
perspective of what you need to be at
your best and if you lose that
perspective even though you still do in
your routine sometimes you just - you're
just 80 70 60 % of what you should be so
you're not gonna be the best husband
you're not gonna be the best father the
best employer the best employee you just
you know it's just so at this point I
feel like I have to be at my best
physically do my if I feel like I have
to stretch I gonna stretch breathe joke
have fun list and party whatever you
know and then when I feel like man I'm
so happy I could not eat so and then I
can go and do my service you know and no
because the window of life is smaller
and now for me it becomes I don't have
too much time so I don't waste time to
do what people expect from me I try to
do things are really relevant to my soul
like this Federation now I when I dream
I don't dream small I dream like I make
like a very space for a hue day the
biggest dream I can dream and I see that
moment you know that level of need for
the community and the level of position
I have to be the reference for that
shift in the direction of our culture in
our knowledge I feel like I could not be
more motivated more happy to engage in
this so and that's always life is about
is just do your best and and and be
excited to be motivated to chew to the
next day there's such a refreshing
attitude your your attitude your your
philosophy on life because I think it's
very easy and I've been I've trapped
myself in it sometimes where you
concentrate too much I'm making money
and concentrate too much I'm being
ambitious and you forget the quality of
life yes your focus is almost entirely
on your quality of life yes you know
because like I said man how much cost
your motivation how much cost your
friends how much costs your health how
much cost your intelligence those things
is priceless I mean if you take those of
your life you take a motivation of your
life can be be okay it's can be the
biggest so if you if you ask me if I
want to have do gates life I don't know
I don't know him so it's not a based on
his bank account is based on how happy
he is how horny he is how you know how
how how motivated he is to wake up and
do his thing
you don't like to horny I don't
so so that's that's a very essential
thing which sometimes sleep through
people's fingers and and the priorities
in the daily you know in the payments
and so I put you in a role where I feel
like if you tell me in the past
what's the courage what's the opposite
of courage I want to say cowardness
because either you tough enough to to
challenge and to fight or chew or in the
Newell coward and you chicken out so
that's in the past was like the opposite
of courage it's very hard to measure
this in those days and I believe the
opposite of courage today is conformity
you know as people get conformed oh I I
don't like my wife the way I used to
like but I'm never gonna divorce because
I'm afraid to lose my house or the
situation is so established so I'm gonna
keep so I don't like this job but I'm
gonna keep here because better than his
so in other hands if you if you get
caught on that kind of compromise to to
maintain because you you afraid to risk
let's keep you like one step behind from
you follow your heart follow the
ambition you 18 years old you don't
think place like I say yeah let's go to
Australia you think okay let's go poom
but when you feel to say Australia what
I gonna do there may be one so it's
different you know
[Laughter]
yeah so that's kind of pretty much where
keep you from be at your best because if
you willing to sacrifice if you willing
to to broke new new challenges if you
willing to you in a stage of liveness
and an excitement and unpredictability
who make you feel like you in heaven you
know every time I was engaging in a
compromise or a fight was something I
thank you like I have my routines prior
fight one of them is at the day of my
fight I wake up and I thank you God to
be alive and I acknowledge how perfect
will be that day if I die today
I was a baby a perfect day if I died
because I have you know I accomplished
my think I'm in my mission I
representing my family so I don't want
that you tap I go there to die like I
have to kill me it's no I'm I'm never
gonna tap so but that's not a sport like
orientation this is a philosophical
Honor representation you know it's not
something I teach my snow you should not
tap no it's not like that
it's about how I feel how I feed my kids
how I follow my tradition so in
engagement I'm not gonna be the one who
gonna quit did I have to kill me
my brother he can throw the towel but
for me is unacceptable you know I do
give up from my life so based on that
kind of spirit or guidance my life is
very intense my life is very I mean
directed to accomplish give up is not an
option you know I can do I can direct my
my my focus I can give up from something
to go somewhere else but I never will
give up from something because I feel
like I cannot reach there I may say ok
that's not for me I go somewhere else
but if I still focus I will take those
Falls I will take those obstacles as a
motivation to just set up a new strategy
to try again you know I'm very
competitive in a sense
I like the perfection of things so this
is like a situation where I put you in a
situation where you have no either you
go forward or you don't but don't stay
in the middle don't try just waiting for
people who are waiting for more those
are kind of things gonna stack you back
in life and and just make you feel like
passing through life as you enough you
haven't you know you in relevant you
know is very weak that's a beautiful way
to end this thank you very much brother
let's make this sometime again
absolutely one more things we could do
this forever I'm sure on anything we
could do to help your association I'm
100% committed to making the state of
jiu-jitsu better you know improving on
what was going on that's what I'm also a
JGF calm so we are true on that and
definitely you want to be invited for
the development council thank you very
much so go there JJ GF dot-com enjoy it
Hicks and Gracie thank you very much
thank you John thank you to our sponsors
thanks to Squarespace com go to court
squarespace.com use the code word Joe
and save 10% off your first purchase
thanks also to honor calm go to onn I T
use the code word Rogan and save 10% off
any and all supplements we will be back
in a little while with Bert Kreischer
much love my friends
[Music]